the universe is so amazing and diverse
countless stars are scattered across its
expanses and each and every one of them
is uniquely mysterious and remarkable
every day dozens of new stars are
detected and the exoplanets orbiting
them are just as unique still while
striving to discover other worlds we
should not neglect our own system the
only place in the universe with
conditions favorable for the Genesis and
evolution of Life as We Know It
there are eight planets in the solar
system as well as dozens of satellites
and millions of minor celestial bodies
which remain understudied even in spite
of the long years of observations and
research and today we invite you to take
a little tour and see some of the most
exciting ones
[Music]
we will start out at the very heart of
our system
in the devastating heat of its star the
sun
flying by Mercury which is scorched by
its Relentless Rays we will pass by
Venus shrouded in layers of clouds
after that we will take a break on our
native Planet the Earth A Journey To The
Past will give us insights into how the
looks of its earlier inhabitants changed
from prehistoric saurians to the much
more dangerous and unforgiving creatures
humans
after that we'll proceed to the
mysterious and Barren Mars which will be
followed by a visit to a tremendous area
of cosmic chaos where the trajectories
of millions of celestial objects
intermingle by following an elaborate
root among them will reach Jupiter and
Saturn as well as their mysterious
satellites at the end of our journey we
will get as far as the dark edge of our
system where sun rays and heat don't
reach
here we'll make acquaintance of the
gloomy world of Pluto and its enigmatic
satellite Sharon
after looking at their Barren planes
we'll move further on beyond our
system's boundaries and try to catch up
with the Voyages the space roamers that
have been doggedly cruising towards the
stars for the past half a century let's
get ready and we begin
[Music]
Cosmo
first and outer space
[Music]
on the 21st of November 2021 the Parker
solar probe was just stayed and a half
million kilometers away from the Sun it
was its closest to probe shover to our
star
this means that it was also the first
probe that got to brush against the
sun's Corona the extremely hot outer
layer of our parents star
but why was it necessary to go through a
number of technical difficulties an
approach to sound that close
what is Barker after that it had to get
that near the star to areas where
everything around turns into Ash
to realize the purpose we have to see
what we already know about our system
star
to begin with the sun is a main sequence
star whose age is approximately 4.6
billion years it currently falls into
spectral class g2v which on balance
makes it a typical yellow dwarf the
sun's surface temperature is about
5800 Kelvin
which is
5530 degrees Celsius but it should be
mentioned that there are both colder and
hotter areas to be found on it
incidentally the star's inner layers and
its outer Corona are as scorching hot as
millions of degrees
but for all that they barely contribute
to the visible radiation
the sun's average diameter equals around
1.4 million kilometers which is 109
times that of our Earth
as for the star's Mass it reaches two
times ten to the power of 30 kilograms
or 333
000 times that of the earth and actually
accounts for 99.9 percent the mass of
the entire solar system
we're used to seeing the Sun as small
but in fact it is larger and brighter
than 80 percent of all the stars in our
galaxy that we know of
hydrogen accounts for 92 percent of the
sun's overall volume in one of our
previous videos on Stellar Evolution we
mentioned that it is mainly this gas
that fuels thermonuclear reactions for
the overwhelming majority of stars when
its temperature reaches incredibly High
values
as they merge hydrogen nuclei release
great amounts of energy and transform
into helium which gradually accumulates
in the star's Center at the moment
helium accounts for seven percent of the
sun's volume and 25 percent of its
overall Mass
in addition to helium Stellar matter
contains other elements as well like
carbon oxygen nitrogen and iron but
their percentage is quite negligible
the sun has an elaborate structure and
is made up of several layers which
differ in their properties
a massive core is at the center of the
star estimates show its diameter to
measure 25 percent of the sun's overall
size the cause temperature measures as
much as 14 million Kelvin while one
cubic meter of the material weighs
around
150 tons it is here the thermonuclear
reactions the source of energy for R
star's Luminosity run their course every
second approximately
4.26 million tons of Stellar matter is
transformed into Luminosity as a result
of these processes the core is
surrounded by the so-called radiation
Zone which continues to the point of 0.7
the sun's radius the density of matter
in this area is too great for it to get
mixed up thoroughly and thus to carry
heat to the upper layers of the star
that is why the way energy is
transferred here is this particles of
Stellar plasma are continuously
absorbing photons and radiating them
again mathematical modeling shows that
the temperature in this part of the star
dramatically changes from 7 million
Kelvin in its depth to 2 million Kelvin
on the outer boundary estimates reveal
that a Quantum of light produced by the
core may stay in the radiation Zone from
10 000 to 170 000 years and only then to
move on to the next layer of the Sun
the one lying above known as the
convection Zone forms the sun's
outermost layer and is comparatively
dense
Stellar Mata here is more rarified and
changeable which gives rise to enormous
vortices in the convection Zone these
vortices carry Hot plasma from deeper
regions of the layer to the star's
surface as it were while plasma masses
from the outermost areas slightly cooled
moved down
these convection cells remain stable for
10 to 15 minutes after which they get
destroyed to give rise to new vortices
again this continuous movement of matter
creates a magnetic field which pervades
the entire inner part of the solar
system the sun is also surrounded by an
atmosphere
it is made up of several layers of
elaborate structure the lowest one is
called photosphere
this area emits most of the star's
visible light so when watching the sun
it is actually this Photosphere that we
see
as for its thickness it measures from
100 to 400 kilometers with a temperature
fluctuating between
6600 and 4400 Kelvin or between
6330 and
4130 degrees Celsius
higher up lies a more rarified area
around 2 000 kilometers thick known as
the chromosphere it can be observed from
the earth at the time of a total solar
eclipse or else by employing special
equipment
this area is extremely hot with the
temperature fluctuating between 4000
Kelvin and 20 000 Kelvin
interestingly it's outer border is
covered with specules continuously
active Jets of hot gas spurting up a
staggering 5000 to 10 000 kilometers
high
the uppermost area of the sun's
atmosphere is called the corona it
consists of giant prominences flares and
Emissions that may reach one million
kilometers in size the matter making of
the corona is remarkably rarified and
incredibly hot with an average
temperature one to two million Kelvin
and the Peak at 20 million Kelvin it is
this area that is occasionally crossed
by the Parker probe and every time the
spacecraft immerses deeper and deeper
into the Blazing Abyss
calculations of the energy flow released
by the Photosphere will show it to be
insufficient to heat the chromosphere
and Corona to such mind-boggling
temperatures this means that there are
some physical phenomena concealed in the
Sun that we have not yet discovered
which additionally heat up the upper
layers there are several scientific
hypotheses that attempt to account for
this thermal Paradox according to one of
them the chromosphere and the corona
gain additional energy by despair
reversing magnetic shock waves another
assumption explains it as an effect of
charged particles acceleration in the
star's exceptionally powerful magnetic
field
the Parker solar probe was specially
designed in order to get to the bottom
of these phenomena and to study obscure
processes in the upper layers of the
sun's atmosphere
this probe is part of NASA's project
known as Parker solar probe launched
back in 2009
nine years later on the 12th of August
2018
Parker took off from the surface of our
planet on its one-way Journey to the Sun
to fulfill its mission
however before getting that far it had
to execute a number of Maneuvers to
enter the desired orbit by using Venus's
gravity Parker slowly adjusted its
trajectory drawing ever so closer to the
scorching blazing ball in the center of
our system
it was ready to withstand the star's
searing heat the probe had been designed
with a heat shield and all the equipment
had been made with a view to extreme
conditions to be faced besides Parker's
calculated orbit is supposed to line the
sun's immediate proximity for a
comparatively short time after which it
pulls back and has a chance of giving
out heat to space this alleviates
effects of thermal exposure the probe's
main task is to define the structure and
dynamics of the magnetic fields in the
sun's immediate proximity also Parker is
supposed to gauge the energy flow
emitted by the star to capture particles
of Stellar Wind and to register
wave-like processes in the sun's Corona
as a side mission the probe took photos
of Venus and the comet near-wise as it
was drifting towards our parents star to
deal with the missions successfully the
probe is equipped with a wide range of
scientific instruments like photo
cameras instruments for capturing
particles magnetometers as well as
radiation and radio wave detectors a
number of factors toward this mission in
addition to critical temperatures the
measuring instruments are exposed to an
extremely powerful flow of ionizing
radiation
the sun creates strong interference in
the microwave range around itself which
means that transmitting the data
collected by the probe to the Earth is
no easy matter either
still the Parker probe is carrying on
with its Mission with every completed
spiral of its orbit the distance to the
star shortens in late February 2022 it
is to pass through the sun's Corona yet
again in order to collect a new portion
of data by 2024 the distance between the
probe and the surface of our star will
shrink to become an all-time short just
six and a half million kilometers
estimates show that when the probe is in
its perihelium its Solar Shield may heat
up to
1370 degrees Celsius which is three
times hotter than Mercury's sunny side
and only slightly lower than the melting
point of iron even now the probe is
whizzing at a speed of 163 kilometers
per second in its perihelium but it will
eventually accelerate to 200 kilometers
per second which will make it the
swiftest man-made space object made so
far
probe's life expectancy cannot be that
long
on reaching the closest possible point
to the sun Parker will manage to
complete several orbits around it which
is supposed to take roughly a year
all this time it will keep losing speed
and the scientific instruments on board
will be exposed to extreme temperatures
and Powerful radiation
eventually they will all be out of order
and the probe itself will descend into
the scorching depths of the sun to be
totally swallowed up by a farthemless
ocean of Blazing plasma
but before it happens Parker will beam
great amounts of useful data back to the
Earth which will help us make yet
another step in space exploration this
is a potent proof that Parker's flight
will not have been wasted
[Music]
Mercury lies relatively close to the
Earth
but its exploration has always been
associated with a lot of difficulties on
account of its close proximity to the
sun it can be observed in the sky only
at the very Horizon and this either
shortly before sunrise or immediately
after sunset this is actually why
ancient astronomers took Mercury for two
different celestial bodies which were
given different names
only the advancement of observation
equipment enabled scientists to
gradually reveal some of this unusual
world's Mysteries the accumulated data
shows Mercury to be the smallest planet
in the solar system incidentally it is
even beaten by some satellites
its radius measures
2440 kilometers which is roughly 38
percent that of the Earth
the celestial object is remarkable for
its almost ideally round shape as the
difference between its equatorial and
polar diameters is not over one
kilometer at the same time given its
modest size mercury has a surprisingly
big Mass it equals 3.33 times 10 to the
power of 23 kilograms which is
approximately five and a half percent
that of the Earth comparing Mercury's
parameters with those of celestial
objects close to it in terms of their
size Mercury is heavier than Ganymede
and Titan put together and that in spite
of the fact that both of those objects
diameters are bigger
it is probably due to the fact that
there's a massive metallic core with a
radius reaching as much as 2 000
kilometers accounting for about 57
percent of the planet's volume the core
is enveloped in a 400 kilometer layer of
mantle made up of melt and silicate
rocks
the mantle in its turn is covered with a
hard crust as thick as 15 to 37
kilometers
as for the planet's surface it is vastly
pockmarked with craters their analysis
shows the celestial body not to have
been noticeably geologically active for
the past 3.8 billion years
bright sunlight presents difficulties in
observing Mercury through a telescope
however this had been the only way of
studying the planet until as recently as
the second half of the 20th century
everything changed in 1974 when a space
probe Mariner 10 reached the planet's
environs
it took pictures of 45 percent of the
celestial body's surface and also gauged
its temperature and magnetic field in
addition to that the probe sensors
registered the exceptionally rarified
atmosphere made up of helium and other
gases 30 years later on the 3rd of
August 2004 another spacecraft took off
the face of the Earth messenger it took
a long 11 years to reach its Target but
the little probe did tackle all
obstacles and eventually accomplished
its Mission In the period from 2011 to
2015 messenger beamed back hundreds of
thousands of images for scientists to
study including pictures of Mercury's
almost entire surface thanks to these
pictures important data was obtained in
the celestial bodies inner makeup and
various features of the planet's relief
were detected in including unique ones
in the solar system
also Messengers sensors helped suppliers
with some knowledge about solar wind and
its unusual interaction with the
planet's magnetosphere
Mercury follows an elongated elliptical
orbit around the sun
which takes 88 days to complete
in its perihelium the planet approaches
the Sun as close as 0.31 astronomical
units
with the distance in the aphelium one
and a half times as big at 0.47
astronomical units Mercury's orbital
resonance unique in the solar system is
of special interest
its Stellar day equals
58.65 Earth days which is two-thirds of
the mercurian Year this makes the planet
to face the sun alternately first with
one side then the other in the
perihelium
these regions are exposed to solar
radiation most and are referred to as
hot meridians
one of such regions boasts the largest
geological formation on Mercury
designated on maps as coloris planicia
this name which is translated as a
heated plane is fully Justified as the
temperatures here reach 700 Kelvin or
427 degrees Celsius making this area the
hottest place on the planet
the plane is a gigantic impact crater
measuring
1550 kilometers and accounting for about
two percent of Mercury's total area
estimates show the crater to have formed
approximately 3.9 billion years ago
after a collision of the planet with a
large asteroid measuring as much as 100
meters in diameter Mercury was a young
and hot protoplanet at the time the
impact would have destroyed a great
portion of crust that had barely
solidified and melt and lava would have
spilled over a vast area of the planet's
surface when it cooled and solidified
the plane was bowed by a rocky crust
looking like a bright light spot easily
noticeable against dark valleys
surrounding it the surface of coloris
planisha is pockmarked with a great
number of craters measuring up to 100
kilometers in diameter however the most
outstanding feature on this plane is
Pantheon foci
unique in the solar system this
structure is formed by a radial set of
230 troughs or extension faults with a
width from one to eight kilometers most
of the troughs do not measure over 175
kilometers in length with others running
much further than that
there is a comparatively large crater
apollodorus lying not far from Pantheon
forsy's central point but it is still
not clear whether it has anything to do
with the troughs today there are several
hypotheses as to Pantheon fossise
formation according to one the giant
cracks appeared due to tectonic activity
while another deems the planet's cooling
as the reason colorus planetia is an
area of flames and light however moving
slightly to the north we will find a
land of ice and darkness the tilt of
Mercury's proper motion axis is very
small which is why its polar regions are
perpetually enveloped in dusk
the sun here either hangs by the very
horizon or does not appear in the sky at
all its Rays haven't touched the bottoms
of some of the craters for as long as
millions of years there is no wonder
that borealisplanetia a place
surrounding the planet's North Pole is
the coldest region here the temperature
in some of its areas is around 80 Kelvin
which is 193 degrees Celsius below zero
some deposits of water ice have been
detected here in the shade of the
mountain ridges around craters measuring
up to two meters in thickness they are
covered by a layer of Rocky dust
preventing the ice from evaporation
at the same time some elevations which
do catch sun rays May get as hot as 380
Kelvin or 107 degrees Celsius
interestingly such contrasting areas of
the surface May lie almost next to each
other but the planet's rarified
atmosphere does not allow them to
effectively exchange heat and so the
Stark temperature contrast remains
our tour is getting us to More Southern
latitudes
practically on one parallel with caloris
planicia but three and a half thousand
kilometers to the West there is one of
the largest craters on Mercury
Rachmaninoff
its diameter measures up to 290
kilometers and it's roughly 1 billion
years old
there is a tall Peak ring in its Center
it is formed by tall mountain peaks and
measures roughly 130 kilometers in
diameter the rocks in this area are
different from the rest of the landscape
there of a reddish Hue and signs of
solidified streams can be distinguished
on the surface this structure is assumed
to be a volcanic origin and is a mark of
one of the last volcanic activity events
on the planet
also the lowest point on Mercury's
relief has been registered here which is
minus
5380 meters relative to the average
value for the planet beyond the central
ring there are comparatively smooth and
dark expanses
moving on to the South we will see a
gigantic escarpment stretching for 820
kilometers from Southwest to Northeast
it is called Enterprise rupees which in
some places towers as high as several
thousand meters
there are quite a few escarpments on
Mercury but Enterprise Rupees is the
largest
these bizarre features of terrain are
believed to have formed as the planet
cooled
when Mercury's interior gave away some
of its heat the celestial bodies
slightly shrank losing roughly one
percent in volume this deformed the
planet's lithosphere which produced
gigantic foams
almost half of Enterprise Rupees is
located on the territory of Mercury's
largest crater named Rembrandt
its diameter measures 716 kilometers and
the wide Basin contains a great number
of smaller features of relief
for example there are small mountain
ridges running from the crater's outer
ring to its Center
their width lies within 1 and 10
kilometers and their length May reach
180 kilometers
another ridge forms a ring roughly 450
kilometers in diameter there is also an
elaborate pattern of deep cracks to be
seen on the crater's bottom which
resembles a spiderweb
It is believed that more detailed
studies of the rocks forming the
crater's surface should help us better
understand Mercury's inner makeup and
the processes running in its interior
in spite of close attention paid to
Mercury by astronomers and in spite of
the advancement of observation equipment
the planet is still mysterious and
largely understudied however even
Mercury cannot stay unexplored forever
even at this moment the baby Colombo
spacecraft is on its way rapidly
approaching this Celestial body it has a
joint project of the esa and Japan the
equipment on board the spacecraft will
help collect data on the planet's
surface and atmosphere composition study
the magnetosphere and solar wind and
update information on the relief
features beppi Colombo has passed
Mercury before but there are still a few
elaborate Maneuvers to perform up ahead
to break speed and enter operational
orbit around the planet
it is estimated that this will have
happened by 2025
after which the spacecraft will go on to
collect and transmit data
[Music]
Venus is the sun's second closest planet
lying 0.72 astronomical units away from
the system center its orbital period
equals roughly 225 Earth days
interestingly every 584 days the
distance between Venus and our planet
shrinks to its smallest at approximately
0.25 astronomical units notably Venus
faces the Earth with one in the same
side throughout their closest approach
there is no hard evidence to account for
this fact but it may be either due to
the tidal forces exerted by our planet
or else it could be a mere coincidence
in terms of its physical characteristics
Venus resembles the Earth in many ways
its average radius equals
6052 kilometers or 95 percent that of
the earth and its mass is 4.87 times 10
to the power of 24 kilograms which is
0.82 that of our planet
every 243 days Venus completes a full
rotation on its axis and the rotation
axis is tilted at 3.4 degrees with
respect to the ecliptic plane
for a long time Venus has concealed its
real face from observers on the earth
behind a veil of its dense atmosphere
and thick clouds
this gave rise to a whole plethora of
Highly imaginative hypotheses and
assumptions some of them claimed that
there was a highly Advanced civilization
concealed under the planet's impervious
outer layer While others suggested that
there was a world that was home to
Peculiar life forms
until a certain point in the recent past
assumptions about Venus were to be
confined to the Realms of fancy
space flights and the advancement of
radio location Technologies proved to be
a major breakthrough that made the
desired answers closer than ever
for example it turned out that radio
waves of a certain range pass freely
through the planet's atmosphere and get
reflected from solid rocks
this effect made it possible to make the
first maps of Venus back in 1978 by the
Orbiter Pioneer Venus 1.
Soviet orbiters contributed to the
collected data but the maps were
accurate up to one to two kilometers and
outlined only the largest features of
the venusian terrain this is the reason
why it was necessary to go on to send
the Magellan Orbiter a large specialized
radar in the period from 1990 to 1994
images of 95 percent of the planet's
surface were beamed back to the Earth by
the spacecraft interestingly their
resolution reached 120 meters
The information collected by the
Magellan spacecraft is still considered
the most exhaustive and accurate data
about the venusian surface
before talking about any planet's
surface it's worth looking at its inner
makeup according to the most reliable
and well-grounded Theory Venus has a
metallic core at its Center whose Mass
accounts for as much as 25 of the
planet's overall Mass
observations show that Venus has no
magnetic field which is why the metallic
core is more likely than not in a solid
state
it is embedded in a silicate mantle as
deep as 3000 kilometers
its upper layer is a solid crust whose
average thickness measures as much as 16
kilometers
it is positive that Venus's lithosphere
doesn't form tectonic plates on account
of high temperatures and a high
viscosity of the rocks
this makes the planet's geologic
activity quite different from that in
our Earth
Venus is also peculiar for not having
that many large impact craters large
areas of its surface are covered by
basort planes that formed from
solidified lava
some features of the relief found here
are uniquely venusian and are not to be
found on any other planet in the solar
system
an example of these is tessery highly
ragged mountainous areas resembling roof
tiles arachnoids and coroni are two
other unique types of the planet's
Terrain
round arrival structures with diameters
measuring several hundred kilometers
they appear to be impact craters but
their origin is different rather than
celestial objects in full they formed as
a result of tectonic processes
an unprepared viewer will not easily
notice any features of the venusian
terrain even in processed images that's
why let's take a look at the elevation
map of the planet's surface where areas
of different height are marked by
contrast colors
the region that instantly catches our
eye is the largest elevated feature on
Venus nicknamed Aphrodite Terror
areas like that may well be considered
conditional continents of the planet
Aphrodite terror is a gigantic territory
stretching along the planet's equator
its mountainous relief is rather
elaborate according to different
estimates the length of Aphrodite Terror
May reach 18 000 kilometers and the
width around 5000 kilometers
depending on the method of defining the
continent's borders its area is
estimated in the range from 29 to 41
million square kilometers which is
comparable with the area of Asia
if we look at Aphrodite Terror we will
see three vast areas Adler Reggio thetis
Reggio and David Reggio
the first one of these is located in the
eastern part of the continent and is
notable for the highest volcano on Venus
the distance from its food to its peak
measures around five kilometers and the
overall height above the average level
of the celestial object's surface is
anything from 8.3 to 8.8 kilometers
according to different estimates
the volcano is currently dormant
although there is evidence that it
erupted comparatively recently in
geological terms namely it can be
inferred both from solidified lava flows
and lack of impact craters while the
volcano's slopes
of De Reggio sprawls in the western part
of Aphrodite Terror this is a region
particularly attractive in terms of
tectonic processes
the mountain ridges here run in
different directions which means that
there are several forces tearing at the
crust simultaneously and deforming it
moreover deep crevices have been
discovered here that contain traces of
lava spillage these May well be
considered the most bizarre volcanoes on
the planet
we're moving on to the west to the very
edge of the continent where the alleged
descent points of four Venera probes can
be found and two of the probes were
destroyed by the planet's atmosphere
before reaching the surface all these
are located in the southern part of a
vast lowland region known as Guinevere
planisha it stretches for many thousands
of kilometers and is quite a match to
Aphrodite Terror in terms of area even
though it is called a planicia their air
has an elaborate relief which is a
mixture of various geologic formations
it is thought that the planet's crust
was being crumpled by tectonic forces
for many hundreds of millions of years
and this produced The Ridges and the
folds at the same time the lava spilling
from the crevices spread across and
solidified filling the lowlands with
smooth basord planes as a result this
region is Rich in both flat areas and
clearly defined Uplands
the western part of Guinevere planisha
borders on the so-called beta Reggio
as this vast area looks quite bright in
photos it is one of the first features
of venusian relief that got its own name
beta Reggio is an elevated area which is
more or less round shaped with a
diameter measuring roughly two and a
half thousand kilometers its eastern
part is the final Abode of the debris of
the spacecraft Venera 9 and Venera 10
the spacecraft which beamed back to us
the first ever photos of Venus back in
1975.
they also gauge the atmosphere's
parameters and sampled the soil which
turned out to be similar to basalts back
on the Earth all this information allows
us to assume that beta Reggio is the
largest volcanic Massif on Venus
that is why this area offers highest
chances to discover active volcanoes on
the planet
we're moving on to the north now to the
second largest conditional venusian
continent dubbed Ishtar Terra it
stretches for roughly 8 000 kilometers
east to west and approximately two and a
half thousand kilometers north to south
the territories area equals about eight
and a half million square kilometers
which makes Ishtar Terra only slightly
larger than Australia
in the center is the largest volcanic
Massif on Venus
Maxwell Montes
they tower 11 kilometers high above the
planet's average level and seven
kilometers Above the Rest of the relief
around the highest peak in the center of
the region is a comparatively flat
Plateau measuring roughly 200 by 400
kilometers the difference in height
doesn't exceed one and a half kilometers
so it is extremely difficult to
distinguish separate Peaks as the
measurements are not accurate enough
Maxwell Montes are the coldest region on
the planet the temperature here is as
low as around 380 degrees Celsius and
the atmosphere is about twice as
rarified as near the surface
still it is 44 times denser than that of
the Earth
another thing about this region is that
it looks quite bright in photos which
means that the surface of the Peaks and
slopes is likely to be covered with some
substance which reflects radio waves
remarkably well
it is thought that it could be metallic
compounds with impurities of sulfur like
pyrite hematite or Galena exposed to
high temperatures these substances can
vaporize from the surfaces of lowlands
and then precipitate in colder
mountainous regions as fine grain
reminiscent of snow
while examining the venusian surface you
can't help thinking this are all these
amazing and mysterious places to remain
unexplored by humans is there a chance
of us ever leaving our footprints on
this planet's surface so close yet so
forbidding because the atmospheric
pressure on Venus is about 93 times that
of the earth and the temperature near
the planet's surface is on average
737 Kelvin or 464 degrees Celsius
these conditions are so extreme that
even space probes specially designed to
explore Venus last no more than an hour
as for terraforming Venus this idea
seems totally unrealistic
on the other hand their Rhine Venus's
atmosphere some layers whose temperature
and pressure are close to those of the
Earth in the last century ideas were
even put forward about designing a
habitable base hovering in the planet's
atmosphere suspended from special
aerostats still in reality the actual
possibility of putting such projects
into practice remains an open question
and either way Venus is awaiting her
Heroes and her Secrets will sooner or
later be revealed
foreign
approximately
252 million years ago the Earth's
biosphere suffered from a tremendous
blow almost 96 of marine fauna around 70
percent of land vertebrates and roughly
83 percent of insects perished within a
period really short by geological
standards the causes of This Disaster
are still obscure but whatever it was
the Dreadful Calamity didn't wipe life
off the face of the Earth
quite on the contrary it proved to be a
milestone that marked the beginning of a
new era
this is when they were emerged the most
well-known prehistoric creatures
dinosaurs
the Permian Triassic Extinction event
marked the beginning of the Mesozoic a
new era in the geologic history of the
Earth
it began approximately
252 million years ago and continued for
around
186 million years
this was a time when our planet was
actively transforming and gradually
assuming it's today's looks the most
crucial tectonic process of the epoch
was the splitting of the single
supercontinent Pangea first it broke
down into two land masses laurasia and
gondwana which in their turn went on to
form the continents we know today
with several large mutually independent
territories separated by seas and
Straits the conditions were perfect for
independent ecosystems to emerge which
gave impetus to new evolutionary
adaptations
in terms of climate the Mesozoic was the
warmest era in the entire history of
multicellular life forms
throughout this era there was no ice
Shield even at the pearls that would
cover the ground for a long term
still temperature would drop from time
to time which forced both flora and
fauna to adapt to the newly imposed
conditions the Mesozoic comprises three
periods and the first one is known as
the Triassic it began around
252 million years ago and continued for
around 51 million years this was the
time when tectonic processes in the
Earth's interior were just starting to
break Pangea into separate continents
and the supercontinent remained hell for
most of the period
the Ural Ridge one of the oldest
mountain ridges existing to this day
completed its formation in the Triassic
at the time the mountains were in their
salad days and comparatively High
the period's climate was relatively dry
and hot which is why there were lots of
deserts at the time and the area of
Inland bodies of water diminished there
was 10 to 15 percent of oxygen in the
air for most of the Triassic and then
around 215 million years ago its level
gave a sudden leap to reach as much as
19 percent the reasons for this
phenomenon haven't been established for
certain but it is assumed that it may
have had something to do with the
evolution and spreading of certain
varieties of marine or land plants
prehistoric seed ferns accounted for the
overwhelming majority of the Flora of
the day but later on they were gradually
ousted by more Progressive groups of
plants those included cycas Ginkgo and
prehistoric conifers many of these
orders have survived our day although
now they're not as diverse as they used
to be
marine life meanwhile was following its
own course of evolution the oceans
emptied by the perm Triassic Extinction
were gradually populated by Turtles and
teleosts and the first ichthyosaurus
held the niche of large predators
later on they were to become reptiles
best adapted to Aquatic environment
but in a Triassic these creatures were
still rather primitive
an example of these is symbospondalis
which lived 240 to 210 million years ago
this giant sea saurian measured 6 to 10
meters in length and date mostly fish
this impressive creature had a long thin
body half of which was a flexible tail
its head was rather large and the
elongated sharp muzzle boasted a nice
set of small and sharp teeth
Simba spondylus's limbs looked like
diving fins but it appears they were
used only to stabilize body position in
water
the saurian's skeleton structure
suggests that it traveled through Water
by making wave-like movements and
generally speaking was rather clumsy
the most common representatives of land
defauna of that time were rakeshoria
prehistoric ancestors of dinosaurs
crocodile amorpha and birds as well as
other animal species
by the middle of the period first
dinosaurs evolved from ancient
archasauria as independent species but
there was still a long and hard struggle
for survival up ahead for them
it was only by the end of the Triassic
that dinosaurs started to establish
their dominance in the Earth's biosphere
after sharply growing in size which
incidentally coincided with an increase
of oxygen in the atmosphere
with dozens of films and thousands of
books about horrifying saurians anyone
today would be familiar with what they
looked like
at the same time these Giants seem to
Eclipse other species which are by no
means less important and interesting
for example a legacyphus a small
creature that lived in the late Triassic
around 200 million years ago
this small and Deft little animal was A
genus of cyanodons prehistoric animals
that differed from mammals in some not
very clearly noticeable traits oliga
kyphus had a thin flexible body
measuring around 50 centimeters
it grew fur and generally looked like a
weasel warm-blooded and herbivorous it
was widespread on the territories of
today's North America Europe and China
even though it isn't known whether oliga
kaifus had a pouch on its stomach the
structure of its skeleton allows us to
assume that its babies were quite small
which is typical of today's marsupials
it is also highly likely that
oligokythus fed its babies on milk
another assumption about these creatures
is that they dug Burrows and made homes
there they also took great care about
their babies which may be evidence of a
comparatively High intellect
unfortunately these creatures perished
at the beginning of the Jurassic period
supposedly due to lack of food and
heightened competition still they
remained the oldest prehistoric animals
that look like today's mammals most
the Triassic Jurassic mass extinction
heralded the end of the Triassic period
a great number of amphibians some
arcosauria are the reptiles as well as
many plant orders vanished from the face
of the Earth
among the possible reasons for This
Disaster of volcanic activity a change
in the global ocean level and sudden
climate change either way the extinction
event vacated a number of ecological
niches which allowed dinosaurs to
establish a firmer position on the
evolutionary Arena of the Earth
The Next Period of the Mesozoic was the
Jurassic it began about 201 million
years ago and ended about
145 million years ago which makes it
roughly 56 million years long this was a
time of large-scale tectonic movements
and reformations
it is in the Jurassic that the
supercontinent Pangea finally split to
form several landmasses mutually
separated by shallow Seas if we look at
the map of the Earth at the end of the
Jurassic period we'll be able to
distinguish the shapes of some of
today's continents although they would
be positioned in unexpected places since
the new continents were mutually
independent they are emerged isolated
biosystems that is why some animals and
plants that were abundant on one
continent would be non-existent on
another
the earth's climate was warm and humid
for most of the Jurassic period And by
its end a comparatively short cooling
occurred
great areas on land were covered with
tropical forests which were for the most
part cycas gymnosperms that resembled
palm trees
conifers were also widespread
their looks were reminiscent of today's
cypress trees and pine trees
on land meanwhile there started the
epoch when dinosaurs positively
flourished their diversity was rich and
they held most ecological niches while
dominating almost every single one of
them
among these creatures one could come
across both small saurians the size of a
cat and real giants
herbivorous dinosaurs known as suropita
came to be widespread in the Jurassic
with some typical Representatives like
Brachiosaurus brontosaurus Diplodocus
and others they resembled each other
very much
the largest one Titanosaurus measured as
much as 25 to 30 meters in length and
could weigh over 75 tons
an unusual feature typical of sauropoda
is the so-called sacral brain a widening
in the hind part of the vertebrae that
hypothetically could contain 20 times
more nervous tissue than cranial brain
today it is posited that the sacral
cavity was likely to be filled with a
glycogen body which was a source of
additional nutrition for the giant
soria's nervous system
alongside dinosaurs other animal species
were evolving as well such as mammals
reptiles and arthropods
the oceans were richly populated with
bivalve mollusks which in many ways
resembled their today's descendants
the apex predators in the marine food
chain were various saurians like
ichthyosaurus and plyosaurus
looking at ophthalmosaurus which lived
at the beginning and the end of the
Jurassic period and comparing it with
symbospondylus which lived earlier it
may be hard to believe that these
animals are in fact related
ancestor symbol spondylus
lived to 140 to 210 million years ago
length 6 to 10 meters
elongated body and head badly adapted to
Aquatic environment
descendant
ophthalmosaurus lived 165 to 145 million
years ago
length up to 6 meters streamlined body
vertical tail
well adapted to Aquatic environment
this Marine saurian had a dolphin-like
body with an elegant and Powerful
crescent-shaped vertical tail
it is thought that the animal breathed
atmospheric air and was able to stay
around 20 minutes underwater developed
speeds of over 7 kilometers per hour and
divers deep as 600 meters judging by
ophthalmosaur's teeth structure its diet
consisted for the main part of mollusks
including squid
the animal's eyes were another
distinctive feature in its appearance
their diameter measured around 10
centimeters and they were protected by a
bony sclerotic ring it is thought that a
thalmosaurus could see well in the dark
which was a valuable acid for deep water
hunt and so the animal was free to dive
far down where large saurian Predators
couldn't get
the last period of the Mesozoic Era is
called the Cretaceous it began 145
million years ago and lasted for around
79 million years which makes it the
longest one in the Mesozoic
the continents continued to break apart
throughout the entire Cretaceous India
detached itself from Africa and slowly
drifted in the direction of Asia across
the Indian Ocean South America broke
away as well and made its way westwards
eventually by the end of the period
Africa Australia Greenland North and
South America assumed shapes close to
those of today while Europe and Asia
were starting to get clearly defined
borders
the climate and the Cretaceous was
comparatively cool in the period from
100 to 85 million years ago the average
temperature increased somewhat and then
cooling continued which persisted till
the very end of the ERA this is exactly
when Tyrannosaurus and Triceratops were
around the most widely known dinosaurs
and truly distinctive symbols of the
Mesozoic
still the period is much more notable
for the spread of flowering plants first
trees and then grasses they form Turf
and so strengthened the soils and made
them more fertile while nutritious seeds
served as food for a wide variety of
species this gave evolutionary impetus
to diversification of mammal species and
also for some herbivorous dinosaurs but
on a smaller scale
even though reptiles were dominating in
all the ecological niches of that time
mammals continued to evolve they grew to
be more and more diverse and by the end
of the period it was possible to single
out separate groups like congulates
eulipotifla predators and primates
rep Anonymous which lived around
125 million years ago was one of the
largest mammals of the Cretaceous
its body measured up to one meter in
length and it weighed 12 to 14 kilograms
this creature's appearance may have been
similar to today's Tasmanian devils its
teeth structure suggests that it was a
predator but its limbs were short and
clumsy so probably this animal was a
scavenger incidentally an interesting
find was Unearthed at archaeological
diggings
it was ripponomous skeleton with bits of
a small dinosaur in its abdominal area
this may serve as evidence that some
mammals of the time could hunt small
dinosaur species like satakasaurus and
darkioritys
meanwhile large aquatic saurians had
long been dominating the Seas
ichthyosaurus Plesiosaurus and
Mosasaurus
however around 1995 million years ago
their population sharply dropped after
the extinction event brought about by
the second elsianic anoxic event which
had to do with a sharp decrease of
oxygen in the ocean one of the suggested
possible reasons is increased underwater
volcanic activity
the under the Cretaceous was probably
the coldest time in the Mesozoic all
living creatures set about adapting to
the inexorably dropping temperatures and
dinosaurs were no exception
around 70 million years ago the
territory of today is Northern Alaska
above the Arctic Circle was inhabited by
peculiar dinosaur species
this Soarin is known as nanoxaurus
remotely related to the horrifying giant
Tyrannosaurus Rex this dinosaur
admittedly resembled it but its size was
smaller
the body of nanoxaurus measured around 6
meters and it weighed just around a
thousand kilos that is approximately
eight nine times less than Tyrannosaurus
Rex this shrinking is thought to have
had to do with a lack of available food
in its habitats
forced to survive in the dire conditions
of the far north among snowy stretches
and in the semi-darkness of the Polar
night this dinosaur developed some
unusual features
first of all it is likely that it was
warm-blooded and incidentally the
metabolic processes in its body ran
their course remarkably fast for example
as is the case with today's Birds
secondly nanoxaurus's body was covered
with several layers of down and Feathers
which allowed it to preserve warmth in
the severe Northern climate this
suggests that the northern saurian was
probably an active and fast-moving
Predator but in the conditions of the
Polar night traditional ways of hunting
prey are not that effective that is why
it appears that nanooksaurus had an
exceptionally well-developed sense of
smell and sensitive night vision
these assumptions are confirmed by the
build of its cranium
summer in Northern latitudes were short
and rather cool so additional sources of
warmth were needed for dinosaur eggs so
that the babies developed well
nanoxaurus is thought to hatch its eggs
and to take great care about the young
ones
studies of fossil fines show that the
volume of the brain of this species was
rather big potentially this dinosaur was
as intelligent as most of today's Birds
unfortunately these evolutionary
adaptations didn't save nanoxaurus from
Extinction around 66 million years ago
the Cretaceous paleogene Extinction
event caused all non-avian dinosaurs to
vanish off the face of the Earth
alongside marine saurians pterosaurs and
many other species
still the terrifying saurians left their
imprint in the history of our planet and
the ecological niches vacated by them
were promptly occupied by birds and
mammals this marked the beginning of the
cenozoic era its highest being was the
unique creature that came to be known as
Homo sapiens the self-proclaimed King
above all nature its Evolution has only
just started and time will show what it
has in store for this species
[Music]
the Cretaceous paleogene mass extinction
event heralded the beginning of a new
geological era the cenozoic having
started 66 million years ago it is still
going on
in the course of all this period the
Earth's surface underwent Global
Transformations and offered its expanses
to a great multitude of amazing
creatures
the first period in the new era was
dubbed the paleogene
it started immediately after the
disaster that wiped off dinosaurs and
lasted for 43 million years
our planet's appearance dramatically
changed in this time India crossed the
ocean and virtually rammed into the
south coast of Asia
the Himalayas Rose their peaks up to the
heavens and the Antarctic began to grow
its vast ice Shield
in the first 10 million years the
Earth's biosphere was recovering from
the Fateful blow
with the Old Masters gone agile and
viable animals mammals quickly spread
across ecological niches vacated by them
looking for new forms life evolved and
produced the doer Andrew Sarkis the
Giant and rigid indric ethereum and the
Aquatic archaeoceti the prehistoric
ancestors of today's Wales
many of these fascinating creatures
vanished Without a Trace While others
evolved to adapt to the changeable
conditions
about 23 million years ago the Paleo
Gene was succeeded by the neogene which
lasted around 20 million years it is
divided into two unequally Parks the
longer one of which is God the Maya
scene this was a time of unhurried and
consistent Cooling
ice caps on the earth gradually grew
while the climate became cooler and
drier
the global sea level was falling and
mountain ridges like the Alps and the
Andes on the contrary were Rising higher
as a result of this process the
Mediterranean Sea was cut off from the
global ocean and almost dried up
in its place there remained vast
lowlands covered by salty desert
According to some estimates temperature
in some of its areas reached 80 degrees
Celsius while the atmospheric pressure
at the bottom of this Basin was over one
and a half times the value of what we're
used to
just a few small lakes with extremely
salty water were scattered Across The
Bleak lifeless desert
in that Epoch the vast expanses of our
planet were home to a great number of
bizarre creatures
gigantopithecus an enormous man like ape
related to orangutans over three meters
in height and with a body mass of up to
half a ton forced its way through dense
Asian rainforests
and teledon an ungulate predator and
scavenger the size of a bull terrified
stabbed dwellers as for the ocean its
depths were dominated by Megalodon the
largest carnivorous shark in the history
of the Earth
[Music]
slightly over 5 million years ago the
area which is now known as Gibraltar was
stunned by tremendous earthquake
the rocky Dam that had separated the
Mediterranean Sea from the Atlantic
Ocean for hundreds of thousands of years
finally gave way
and millions of tons of water gushed
into the gigantic lifeless lowlands
according to estimates the force of the
flow was forty thousand times that of
the Niagara Falls
and it took only two years for the sea
to fill up again
at the same time thousands of tons of
salt were buried under layers of sand
and rock of remarkable thickness and
that's where it remains to this day
this tremendous event dubbed the zanclin
flood is considered to be the beginning
of the playaacini park that was to last
for two million 745
000 years
by that time the continents had drifted
to stay in the places we're used to
seeing them but some relief features
were just starting to form
for example North and South America was
still separated by a wide Strait at the
beginning of the year Park
and the Rocky Mountains were just
starting to grow
the earth's climate in the first half of
the ply scene was comparatively warm our
planet's average temperature was two to
three degrees higher than it is now
although these extra degrees were not
distributed across the planet evenly the
climate in the tropical latitudes
resembled that of today but northern
areas were much warmer the Arctic was
not covered in ice permanently and dense
Conifer forests reached the northernmost
areas of Eurasia
still it should be born in mind that the
continent's Border used to lie slightly
more to the South than it does now
because the sea level at the time was an
average 25 meters higher than today on
account of the higher temperature
meanwhile today's humans first ancestors
inhabited the African continent
rdpithecus say helanthropus and orarin
the Unearthed remains of these ancient
primates date four to six million years
back
their body build is still very far from
that of humans there is no doubt that
these creatures were Advanced Apes
rather than humans but still they had
taken the first step in evolution of a
new life
features of their discovered skeletons
reveal a tendency to developing an
upright posture even though tree
climbing habits manifested themselves
very clearly still
as for these creatures cranial capacity
it was bigger than that of chimpanzees
and the teeth structure was similar to
that of later species what was it that
forced the ancient pyramids change so
much
a possible reason could be that
approximately three million years ago
the Continental Plains of North and
South America collided and caused a
rapid rise of rocks
The Straits between the two continents
was cut off by the Isthmus of Panama
which blocked the passage of warm ocean
waters at around the same time the Rocky
Mountains considerably gained in height
thus forming a barrier between the
Atlantic and the Pacific air currents
with all these factors combined the
Earth gradually cooled and some parts of
it grew to be icebound the North Pole
was gripped with an ice Shield Greenland
started to build up tons of ice cap
while the areas of African forests
shrank giving way to steps and savannas
Treetops made great habitats they're
safe and comfortable and provide one
with plenty of food this is what ancient
primates agreed on
they adapted to the tree climbing
lifestyle extremely well
however the global climate change
eliminated the greater part of the
African forests
thousands of species lost to habitats
they were used to and so many of them
vanished off the face of the Earth
others were forced to adapt to survive
in the new conditions
today the Savannah concept is the most
developed and well-grounded hypothesis
of anthropogenesis
according to this concept the deficit of
their usual food and lack of woods four
star ancestors out into the Savannah
riddled with unknown dangers
by this time they were already capable
of moving around and two legs and using
primitive tools just like all man like
apes these skills were vital for
survival in the new conditions
easily digestible fruit and plants were
sparse in the savannah and rough grass
and leaves were inedible for the
primates
tapping into animal sources of food
became key to survival
however one is supposed to be fast as
strong to hunt successfully and this is
what our ancestors lacked
only developing an upright posture could
give them the necessary Edge in these
circumstances
upright walking not only increased the
speed of movement but also allowed
citing both potential game and danger
from far off
when the body is in the vertical
position strong hands with prehensile
fingers are free
so a stick or a sharpened Stone can be
used much easier
by forming small tribes the new
inhabitants of the Savannah could hunt
were at the very least take the kill of
other Predators away from them by force
it is assumed that the necessity to
coordinate actions in the process
stimulated the development of the brain
and primitive speech
gradual evolution in the course of
several million years endowed the
ape-like card epithecus and say hello
anthropus with human features
that's how Australopithecus came to be
this agile smart but not very big
creature appeared on the territory of
Africa in the period from 4.2 to 1.8
million years ago
analysis of their fossilized remains
revealed them to have been 120 to 140
centimeters in height and to have
weighed around 40 kilograms
unlike other primates Australopithecus
moved around primarily on two legs
although its posture remained stooped
as for its brain even though it was
larger than that of human-like Apes the
differences in its inner makeup were
many skill
it is now that australopithes lived in
tribes and could cooperate for hunting
and fighting enemies
research shows that early species use
deadly objects close at hand while later
ones learned to make the most basic and
primitive tools to work and defend
themselves with
in spite of all that most individuals
didn't live to be older than 20 because
of illnesses injuries and wild animals
attacks
apparently the predators of that time
saw australopithes exclusively as a food
source back then Dinah felis was around
a large saber-toothed cat distantly
related to smilodentini which were to
emerge later
diggings reveal that it preferred living
not far from australopith's camps
clearly saw them as easy prey slightly
larger than today's leopards Diana felis
was more thick set and more powerfully
built with our weight reaching 120
kilograms these Predators were around 70
centimeters tall
it is next term possible to fight this
kind of animal single-handed and
probably the Beast could be driven Away
by our ancestors only by giant effort
of course Dinah felis hunted not only
australopithes antelopes or wild boars
for example were also part of its diet
most animals inhabiting the Earth of
that time resemble today's species
however there were some real Monsters
Among them too
for example in North and South America
there lived several species of
flightless predatory birds of the forest
rocket eye family whose largest
individuals reached three meters in
height
their skulls measured as much as 75
centimeters with a powerful beak
accounting for most of it
thanks to their reindeer legs the birds
were able to develop great speeds
fortunately mankind didn't have to face
these monsters as the forest Rockets
died out completely around a hundred
thousand years ago much earlier than
America's first ancient tribes had
settled there the ancient jungles
meanwhile were home to another Giant
an elephant-like Beast dinotherium whose
Mass reached 14 tons and whose height
measured three and a half to four and a
half meters of all land mammals ever To
Tread the surface of our planet only
intric ethereum and mammoths were larger
these distant relatives of elephants are
thought to have inhabited the forests of
Asia and Africa subsisting mainly on
tree foliage
their trunks were probably shorter and
thicker than those of the elephant and
the most outstanding feature in their
appearance is that a long massive tusks
protruding from the mandible
two million 588 000 years ago a
tremendous event occurred which got the
name of the ghost matiama reversal
the Earth's magnetic poles swapped
places and door the magnetic lines
changed their directions
the transformation was accompanied by a
weakening of the planet's magnetic field
which decreased by four times this means
that cosmic rays lethal to all living
things could now reach the Earth's
surface
and even though this phenomenon was
around for just approximately fifteen
thousand years which is negligible by
geological standards it caused several
species to massively die out
this magnetic reversal is seen as a
milestone marking the beginning of a new
geological period the quaternary
it is divided into two epochs the first
of which is called the pleistocene
it started 2588
000 years ago and finished just 12 000
years ago
periodic cooling accompanied by the
growth of ice caps was typical for the
climate of that time in between ice ages
temperatures grew and dice caps melted
which made the sea level to rise
these frequent fluctuations in the
climate forced living things to adapt to
these changes quickly has stimulated the
process of evolution
gradually evolving australopiths gave
rise to two large branches of primates
parathropus an extinct genus today and
Homo among others represented by today's
humans
however the three branches have existed
for a considerably long time in the
competitive conditions of a struggle for
survival
The evolutionary way from higher
pyramids to humans was not straight and
clear-cut
there were plenty of dead ends and forks
at least 24 different species roamed our
planet at different times whose
Representatives could be referred to as
humans to this or that degree
The evolutionary process of humans and
our ancestors is always paid a lot of
attention to
and details are constantly being updated
it should be born in mind that evolution
is a very slow process at least two to
three million years is needed for
species to completely part their ways
and into breed to give rise to viable
hybrids
meanwhile the entire history of the homo
the genus including today's human
species amounts to around 2.5 million
years
with our most ancient ancestors taken
into account this figure can be pretty
much doubled also many populations
inhabited neighboring areas which means
that there were probably quite a lot of
hybrids out there in the natural world
it should also be born in mind that
intra-specious variation in humans is
quite High there are noticeable
differences between men and women and
people of different traces also
demonstrate clearly diverse features it
is thought that ancient species divided
into races as well some of which may
erroneously have been classified as
separate species by scientists new
archaeological finds help to correct
these errors and Supply important
details to our knowledge
in spite of all their Progressive
features australopiths were rapes to a
greater degree than they were humans the
first universally recognized
representative of the human species was
a so-called Homo habilis or handyman
digging show that handyman lived on the
territory of Africa in the period from
2.3 to 1.5 million years ago it had a
more developed brain than nostril
epithecus and was able to make primitive
labor tools the height of this species
individuals was around 1.2 meters with a
mass likely to be 50 kilos or less
interestingly it was the first creature
whose big tail was located in one row
with the other Terrors as is the case
with today's humans this could be seen
as evidence of complete adaptation to an
upright posture
another important parameter was the
structure of the Jaws which could
indicate a gradually developing ability
to produce articulate speech foreign
[Music]
years ago and Homo erectus or upright
man
different scientists classify them
either as close evolutionary branches or
as subspecies of one species
in the course of migrations these
representatives of the human race
settled on the territories of Africa
Asia and Europe which stimulated
numerous evolutionary branches one of
them eventually produced homo sapiens
ancient people whether neanderthals or
Homo sapiens lived in tribes and
practiced a nomadic lifestyle
living by gathering and hunting they
were forced to constantly migrate and
move to New unexplored areas
in this manner primitive tribes
gradually settled all over the
continents except the Antarctica
around 50 000 years ago exploration of
Australia began and about 24
000 years ago people reached North
America for the first time via the
Bering isthmus
the spread of primitive tribes across
the globe coincided with mass
extinctions of the megafauna in the
pleistocene in the period from 50 000 to
10 000 years ago mammoths and giant
sloth megatherium vanished off the face
of the planet followed by saber-toothed
cats and other Predators who were unable
to keep up the fierce competition for
food perhaps humans would have met the
same fate but around 12 000 years ago an
Ice Age came to its sand and our
planet's climate became warmer and more
humid the fertile valleys of Mesopotamia
and the Niles Estuary allowed our
ancestors to lead a non-migratory
gathering lifestyle a later to form
fully fledged agricultural communities
after the so-called Neolithic Revolution
that was the end of the pleistocene
which heralded in yui park in the
history of our planet
the Holocene was a time of robust growth
of the human civilization Technical and
social progress destructive Wars and
ecological disasters
by choosing a unique path of evolution
man-made first steps on completely new
and unexplored territories beyond our
planet
early time will show what this path will
lead to
[Music]
Mars lies approximately one and a half
times as far from the Sun as the Earth
in contrast to our planet its radius is
twice as small its mass is around 10.7
percent that of the earth and the Free
Fall acceleration on the surface is
almost three times as little the
temperature fluctuates between 153
degrees Celsius below zero at the pearls
and 35 degrees Celsius above zero at the
equator
the area of Mars's surface is roughly
the same as that of all our continents
combined its terrain is extremely
diverse with some geological features
reminiscent of those of our planet and
others quite unique and peculiar
the surface of Mars is currently closely
observed from the planet's orbit by
eight automatic space probes the data
collected by them reveals that there is
a vast light spot in the planet's
Western Hemisphere this region is the
largest volcano in the solar system and
it is known as Olympus Mons today this
is the starting point of our tour around
the red planet
Olympus Mons towers as high as 26
kilometers over the plains surrounding
it
this is roughly two and a half times the
height of Mount Everest
it is assumed to be a shield volcano
formed with multiple sheets of
solidified lava according to today's
assumptions about the planets inner
makeup there are no tectonic plates
under the surface which is why Magma's
eruption Point can remain in the same
spot for a long time for hundreds of
millions and even billions of years that
accounts for the fact why ejected lava
spills out to cover incredibly vast
areas with a layer that subsequently
turns into a rocky Shield
the average diameter of Olympus Mons
measures around 600 kilometers and its
area is over 300 000 square kilometers
these figures are comparable with the
area of an average sized European
country like Poland or Italy
a giant depression formed with six
calderas or collapsed volcanic craters
is located in the center of the volcano
the diameter of the depression measures
around 85 kilometers and its depth
reaches as far down as three kilometers
Olympus Mons is so high that the
atmospheric pressure at the top is 50
times lower than the foot since the
atmosphere on Mars is about 160 times
more rarified than that of the Earth the
conditions on top of the volcano are
slightly short of those in the vacuum
that is why the red planet's highest
mountain cannot expect any visitor
probes the atmospheric density would be
too low for parachutes to slow down a
descending capsule with a Mars Rover
inside
with the average slope of Olympus Mons
quite small at only five percent the
volcano's edges and an almost sheer
abysses of up to seven kilometers high
it still hasn't been established for
certain how such enormous slopes came to
form According to some assumptions it
was done by an ancient ocean on Mars
Other hypotheses held sandstorms
accountable which continuously rage in
this area
when we climbed down from Olympus Mons
and fly over its surroundings we can see
that there are lots of overlapping
ridges and isolated mountains some of
these formations stretch as far as a
thousand kilometers from the volcano's
Edge it is assumed that they may have
formed as the Giant mountain slopes were
eroding or else due to movements of
ancient ice caps
whizzing on South East from Olympus Mons
we will find ourselves in a vast region
known as tharsis
this volcanic Upland formed by
solidified streams of lava covers
roughly one-fourth of the entire
planet's surface its area of around 30
million square kilometers is comparable
with that of Africa
interestingly the Upland is 10
kilometers higher than the planes
surrounding it and its age could be
about 3.7 billion years there are a
great number of volcanoes here some of
which only slightly smaller than Olympus
Mons are seal mons for example Rises as
high up as 19 kilometers which makes it
the second highest peak on Mars with a
summit Caldera measuring 110 kilometers
the overall diameter of the mountain is
over 400 kilometers
a unique natural phenomenon can be
observed over the volcano every year for
a short time as sun rays warm the
mountains slopes small dust spirals into
a dense Cloud helped Along by air
streams going upward This Cloud May
float up to 30 kilometers above our sea
of mons and may be scattered by winds
across vast areas
vertical pits can be seen in different
places all over the Upland they are
quite deep with the bottoms quite
unobservable the diameter of the largest
one measures around 150 meters and its
depth cannot be less than 178 meters
these pits are thought to be collapsed
Lava Tubes
thalasses is made up of dozens of
overlapping shield volcanoes in the
billions of years of their eruptions
great amounts of CO2 and water vapor
were released into the Martian
atmosphere mathematical modeling shows
that the amount would be enough to
shroud the planet with an atmosphere one
and a half times as dancers that of the
earth these estimates are in direct
evidence of the fact that in the past
conditions on Mars may have been more
favorable for life to originate there
than now
with its gravity comparatively weak
however the planet failed to retain its
atmosphere and was eventually stripped
of it
moving on to the east from the plateau
we will get to the region known as
vallis marineris
it is a network of gargantuan kanyas
stretching for up to
4500 kilometers the width of the canyon
reaches 600 kilometers and it's more
than 11 kilometers deep
images reveal that the slopes of most of
the Canyons in the Central and western
parts of Valles marinaris have a
stratified structure typical of deposits
at the bottom of a large body of water
it is quite likely that the Canyons used
to be completely submerged underwater in
the distant past
there are some truly invaluable
paleontological finds to be extracted
from the rock deposits in this region
the eastern part of the valleys are
areas with a rather chaotic relief there
are vast labyrinths made up of
comparatively small Canyons abysses
mountains and plateaus
further north the terrain evens out into
a relatively smooth plane known as
Christ planitia its vast areas became
the final resting place for the debris
of the Sojourner Mars Rover and also for
the Viking 1 probe which sent the first
color images of Martial Landscapes to
the Earth as far back as a 1976.
according to the widely accepted
hypothesis today vallis marineris came
to be in the early stages of the
planet's formation erosion and
geological processes were to deepen and
widen the Canyons later on one version
has it that the systems of kazmatis is
thought to have formed after volcanic
eruptions on the tharsis Upland another
version claims Utopia planitia to be the
cause for their formation which lies on
the other side of the planet
this vast round lowland is likely to be
an impact crater from an extremely large
asteroid that would have hit the
planet's surface the planetsha's
diameter measures some 3 300 kilometers
the terrain of the surface itself is
rather flat and smooth
there were several attempts to explore
Utopia planitia by different space
probes
in 1979 the Viking 2 Lander beamed back
panoramic images of its surface to the
Earth in 2016 the charade radar on the
mro probe located Rich deposits of water
ice mixed with dust Underground
in May 2021 the Chinese Rover jurong
touched down on Utopia planitia it has
covered over 1 000 meters of the red
planet's surface by now and has beamed
back hundreds of images unfortunately it
cannot dig as far down as the
water-carrying layer with the latter as
deep as 1 to 10 meters down
in the north Utopia planisha borders on
the status Borealis a giant lowland
surrounding the northern part of the
planet and covering about 40 percent of
its total area
moving Southwest from the center of
Utopia planitia we will reach
icdisplanetia
the region on its Western Edge has been
the focus of people's special attention
for almost eight months now of course it
is all about the Jezreel crater it is
likely that millions of years ago there
used to be a body of water here that has
dried up by now
the perseverance Mars Rover and
Ingenuity the first ever helicopter
flown beyond the Earth have been
exploring the bottom of the crater since
the 18th of February 2021.
the Jezreel crater was chosen from the
mission because it appeared one of the
most promising places to discover traces
of Martian life
the crater is positive to have formed
around 4 billion years ago after a
massive Celestial body fell on Mars
the impact crater measured some 49
kilometers
as I've already mentioned it is thought
that it used to be filled with water and
the Hesperian of the geological history
of Mars is singled out as the most
likely period for that the hesperians
started some three and a half billion
years ago and continued for around a
billion years atmospheric pressure on
the planet at the time is estimated to
have been comparable with that on the
earth with the surface temperature
reaching 50 degrees Celsius
Rock samples recently extracted from the
crater's Bottom by the perseverance
Rover a hard evidence of that they still
have to be transported to the Earth for
deeper analysis but it is clear even now
that at some point the rocks have
continuously been in close contact with
liquid water
perseverance has already delighted
scientists with great amounts of useful
data and the mission is still far from
being completed
the probe is designed for 14 years of
operation which means that there are
still hundreds of fines to extract and
kilometers of Martian terrain to cover
that is why our tour around Martian
expanses is not yet over
[Music]
of course we'll be talking about the
main asteroid belt one of the most
changeable and mysterious areas in the
solar system
today over 300 000 small celestial
bodies found here have been given names
and numerical designations interestingly
their overall number May well reach over
a million the starting point of studying
the asteroid belt may be defined at 1801
when astronomers spotted a mysterious
object in the sky after a long and hard
surge for the fifth planet
in terms of its parameters it appeared
to be a planet but happened to be so
small that even the most advanced
telescopes of the day couldn't
distinguish its disc the researchers saw
the newly discovered object as a bright
dot like a star it was dubbed series and
very soon similar celestial objects of
this class were discovered a new term
had to be introduced to refer to them
these unusual astronomical bodies came
to be called asteroids which literally
means star-like
apart from asteroids this area in the
solar system contains great amounts of
cosmic dust while slowly spiraling up
its tiny particles scatter sun rays and
create a very faint wide glow this glow
is referred to as zodiacal light
interestingly in Equatorial areas of the
earth it can be seen with a naked eye
for a long time the following hypothesis
used to be widely accepted asteroid belt
objects were thought to be debris of a
destroyed planet
however today this assumption doesn't
really hold water
first of all the mass total of all the
objects of the main asteroid belt is too
small and equals just three times ten to
the power of 21 kilograms
or four percent the mass of the Moon
even allowing for the fact that the
greater part of asteroids would have
left about a while ago the total mass of
the rocket debris still falls short of
making up an object with Dimensions
comparable to those of a proper planet
secondly estimates show that large
celestial objects cannot form in this
area of the solar system on account of
Jupiter's gravitational influence
mathematical modeling revealed that the
largest formations in the asteroid belt
have never measured over a thousand
kilometers in diameter the gravitational
influence of their Mighty giant neighbor
rendered their orbits highly unstable
which made potential protoplanets
Collide and disintegrate into smaller
bits traces of these collisions can
still be observed most objects of the
main belt group together to form the
so-called asteroid families populations
of asteroids have similar makeup and of
the same origin it is thought that they
formed as a result of such destructive
collisions the borders of the main
asteroid belt are rather blurred most of
the objects making it up lie within 2.06
to 3.27 astronomical units from the Sun
these boundaries are predefined by
Jupiter's tidal forces and are referred
to as Kirkwood gaps any celestial
objects getting into these zones
experience the massive gas giants strong
gravitational influence which
destabilizes their orbits this is the
reason why the space object count here
is considerably lower than Beyond
Kirkwood gaps can be found not only on
the conventional borders of the belt but
inside it too two of the most clearly
defined gaps lied 2.5 and 2.82
astronomical units away from the Sun the
asteroid belt is also conventionally
divided into two large areas inner and
doubt about
the border between them is a Kirkwood
Gap with a radius measuring 2.5
astronomical units which care inside
with the highest orbital resonance with
Jupiter it's in the outer part of the
main belt that the largest object in
this area of the solar system is
situated
series
this celestial object used to be thought
a planet than an asteroid but eventually
in 2006 it was given the status of a
dwarf planet it was possible to do so
thanks to the fact that Ceres has a
spherical shape unlike the absolute
majority of the other objects and about
its diameter measures around
940 kilometers and its mass 9.4 times 10
to the power of 20 kilograms which
incidentally accounts for around a third
of the overall mass of the asteroid belt
this makes series approximately 6 000
times lighter than our planet the
furthest point of the dwarf planets
orbit from the Sun is 2.9 astronomical
units
when a series is at its perihelion the
distance to our system center measures
around two and a half astronomical units
at this point the planetoid's surface
temperature May reach 239 Kelvin or 33
degrees Celsius below zero although its
average temperature is noticeably
smaller at just
167 Kelvin or 106 degrees Celsius below
zero
the celestial body is thought to be made
up of a rocky core enveloped in a cryo
mantle around a hundred kilometers thick
water ice accounts for up to half of the
dwarf planet's volume or 20 to 30
percent of its mass
the inner part of the belt Harbors the
largest and most massive known asteroid
in the solar system
Vesta
the object's average diameter measures
roughly 525 kilometers
and its mass is around 2.6 times 10 to
the power of 20 kilograms which is
almost four times as little as that of
series The asteroid's Orbit is rather
elongated with its aphelian 2.57
astronomical units and its perihelion
around 2.15 astronomical units away it
takes the celestial body 3.6 Earth years
to complete a full orbit around the sun
vest is also remarkable for being the
only asteroid visible to the naked eye
it can be seen not only on account of
its impressive Dimensions but also
thanks to its comparatively light
surface that reflects about 42 percent
of light shed on it besides the minimal
distance between Vesta and the Earth
isn't that great at just
177 million kilometers or 1.18
astronomical units
it is assumed that Vesta is a fully
fledged planet in terms of its inner
makeup it appears to have a metallic
core made up of nickel and iron as well
as a rocky mantle the surface
temperature of the asteroid is currently
fluctuating between -190 and minus 20
degrees Celsius but it used to be much
warmer in the past
dark areas to be seen on the surface in
the Western Hemisphere are highly likely
to be besold planes such terrain
features may have formed as a result of
volcanic activity or Collision events
with massive astronomical bodies the
most outstanding geological feature on
the asteroid is the giant impact crater
referred to as Ria Sylvia whose diameter
measures up to 500 kilometers and its
depth is around 25
000 meters
the second largest mountain in the solar
system is situated at its Center
towering higher than 22 kilometers
impressively the crater's diameter
almost equals vest as size it looks like
the asteroid collided with a really
large object at some point in the past
the Collision would have produced not
only the rear Sylvia crater but also a
great number of small bits which are now
classified as the family of vesta's
numerous asteroids
the family counts over 15 000 objects
making up around five percent of all
celestial bodies of the main belt known
to science today
it is posited that most asteroid
families came to be as a result of
destructive collisions of two large
celestial objects
sometimes the debris are mutually
attracted by gravity forces which
usually blend them into a new
astronomical object
however it would have lost its
monolithic nature and sometimes
astronomers informally call such
formations Rubble piles
for example Sylvia one of the largest
objects in the asteroid belt seems to
fall into this category of celestial
bodies
its parameters are 384 by 262 by 232
kilometers with a mass 1.5 times 10 to
the power of 19 kilograms this makes the
asteroids average density just 20
percent higher than that of water
estimates show that cavities May account
for 25 to 60 percent of its volume it
takes Sylvia 6.5 years to complete a
full orbit around the sun
the object's Orbit's furthest point from
the center of the system is up to 3.7
astronomical units in its perihelion
Sylvia gets as close to the Sun as 3.2
astronomical units
it is assumed that some bits of debris
left after a collision are not attracted
to other bits but rather become
satellites of the new Celestial body
Sylvia is known to have two such
companions Romulus with a diameter
measuring 18 kilometers and Remus
measuring around seven kilometers
their makeup hasn't been studied yet and
it is highly likely that these objects
are not monolithic either
besides Sylvia May theoretically have
smaller satellites as well which haven't
been detected yet
Palace is another remarkable object in
the asteroid belt it was discovered back
in 1802 right after series and is the
second largest asteroid in the belt
the average diameter of the celestial
body is around 512 kilometers and its
mass is roughly 2 times 10 to the power
of 20 kilograms which is approximately
25 percent less than that of Vesta
the asteroids orbit is exceptionally
elongated and tilts to the ecliptic
plane at 35 degrees that is the reason
why the astronomical body is so hard to
investigate with probes
as for its orbital period it takes
Palace around 4.6 years to orbit the Sun
in the course of which the distance to
the system center changes more than one
and a half times with its perihelion 2.1
astronomical units its aphelion is 3.4
astronomical units away palace's surface
is widely pockmarked with craters much
more so than the largest series avasta
studies of the chemical composition of
the asteroid's surface reveal that it
mostly consists of silicate rocks with
small amounts of iron and water just
like Vesta this Celestial body is
thought to be one of the few potential
protoplanets that are still around which
means that studying it may yield
important information about the
formation process of the solar system
unlike Vesta most asteroids cannot be
seen either with the naked eye or
through amateur telescopes one of these
elusive objects is called interramnia
admittedly one of the most mysterious
objects of the main asteroid belt
this is an irregular shaped asteroid
with parameters
362 by 348 by 310 kilometers
and its mass accounts for roughly 1.2
percent of the overall mass of all
objects and about in spite of its
relatively large size however interamnia
remains largely understudied one of the
difficulties thwarting scientific
progress here is the asteroid's dark
surface which absorbs around 93 percent
of light shed on it
interamlia falls into the exceptionally
rare spectral class F which is a
subclass of carbonaceous asteroids
research of Its Reflection shows that
the color of the celestial body's
surface is even which means that
interramnea hasn't experienced big
collisions for quite a long time
interramneous density is not that great
at just twice that of water
the asteroid is thought to be made up of
a hard Rocky core enveloped in a thick
layer of ice the surface is covered with
great amounts of fine dark dust
it takes enter ramnia around five years
and four months to complete a full orbit
around the sun
it's a feeling is on the opposite side
from four largest objects of the main
belt and the distance from the asteroid
to the sun varies from 2.5 to 3.5
astronomical units in theory inter
Romania's orbit crosses the trajectories
of such large objects as Ceres and
Palace but estimates show that chances
of their colliding with each other are
small
there are millions of objects in the
main belt from dwarf planets to Tiny
meteoroids the size of a cobblestone
however distances between them measure
thousands upon thousands or even
millions of kilometers that is why
spacecraft crossing the belt would be
running an almost negligible risk of
getting hit by any astronomical body
still mathematical modeling shows that
around once every 10 million years some
remarkable collisions take place in this
part of the solar system that produce
new debris
even though a manned mission to
asteroids in the main belt will not be
in the pipeline for a long while
some of the asteroids there have been
studied with the help of interplanetary
space probes for example the dawn probe
carried out observations of series
investor in the period from 2011 to
2016.
quite recently the space probe Lucy
blasted off the surface of the Earth
even though its main goal is the
so-called Jupiter Trojans the spacecraft
will approach the object known as Donald
Johansson in the main belt and take its
pictures in 2025
also the launch of the psyche project is
scheduled for July 2022 with the largest
known metallic asteroid of the main belt
as its Target
within the mission the probe is planned
to reach its destination by early 2026
and remain in the asteroid belt for at
least 21 months while studying the
asteroids terrain makeup and magnetic
field
small though they may be asteroids are
important both from the scientific and
practical point of view
some main belt objects are real treasure
troves dating back to the early stages
of the solar system formation studying
them will give us clearer insights into
processes of how planets and other
celestial bodies form and in the future
asteroids will make sources of materials
for space exploration
we don't know when we will be ready for
this
but every new rocket launched into space
brings the space era slightly closer
[Music]
for biological life to originate and
start evolving a medley of a great
number of factors is called for
the chief ones are liquid water and
energy source and a certain chemical
diversity
apart from the earth several more places
in the solar system are potential life
harboring candidates with Mars as the
most prospective one and most closely
studied starting from the recent past
still there are chances of discovering
alien life beyond its orbit too all it
takes is to have a closer look at the
next closest planet to us after Mars if
we look away from the Sun
Jupiter is the largest planet in the
solar system
its mass is 318 times that of the Earth
this is a gas giant made up mostly of
hydrogen and helium
apart from these methane ammonia sulfur
and nitrogen compounds and water ice
have been detected in its atmosphere
in spite of the diversity of chemical
compounds the possibility of finding
life forms on Jupiter itself is
minuscule
what were the absence of any hard
surface high temperatures of the
planet's inner layers and unimaginable
pressure in its interior biological
creatures simply have no chances of
survival
at the same time Jupiter boasts quite a
vast array of moons four of the most
well-known ones IO Callisto Ganymede and
Europa were discovered as far back as in
1609 by Galileo Galilei
quite close to the moon and mercury in
size there on the list of the largest
satellites in the solar system
it is also suggested that Jupiter
accumulated substantial amounts of
thermal energy due to gravitational
contraction when forming as a result it
is now giving off more of this energy
than it is getting from the Sun that is
why the gas giant with all the objects
orbiting it may be seen as a curious
version of the solar system in miniature
at first glance Jupiter's moons may
appear to have no prospects in terms of
searching for extraterrestrial life far
from the Sun they're encased in ice and
their atmospheres are not dense
however on closer scrutiny these
celestial objects reveal something
excitingly promising
Callisto Europa and Ganymede are highly
likely to have liquid oceans under the
ice shell
estimates show that space objects with
concealed oceans may offer favorable
conditions for life even if they are
much further from their star than
planets like our Earth are from the Sun
the thick icy shell on their surface
serves not only as protection against
radiation and meteorite info but also
acts as fairly good thermal isolation
that is why it is feasible that
conditions inside a massive layer of
water may be good enough for life to
originate and evolve there these
assumptions make Jupiter's satellites
some of the most attractive objects for
exploration within the solar system and
now let's have a closer look at each of
them
foreign
is the largest and most massive
celestial object in Jupiter's environs
of all the satellites in the solar
system it is not only the ones sporting
the most impressive Dimensions but it
also resembles a real planet more than
any other
ganymede's radius measures
2634 kilometers which is eight percent
more than that of Mercury
as for its mass it equals 1.48 times 10
to the power of 23 kilograms
this is twice the mass of our moon
interestingly Ganymede is the only
satellite in our solar system with a
liquid metal core and its own
magnetosphere
processes of nuclear Decay take place
and ganymede's interior this heats the
satellite still more with the average
surface temperature 110 Kelvin or 163
degrees Celsius below zero the core on
the other hand is estimated to be as hot
as up to 1500 700 Kelvin
investigations of ganymede's magnetic
field carried out by the Galileo space
probe showed that there may be a
multi-layer salty ocean under the
satellite's icy shell as deep down as
200 kilometers or more the number of
layers May reach four water in each is
of different salinity density and
temperature with the layers separated
from each other by some ice
spectrographic investigations of
ganymede's surface show it to have a
rather rarified oxygen atmosphere this
however isn't an irrefutable proof of
there being biological life on the
satellite molecular oxygen is likely to
form as a result of the exposure of
water ice to ultraviolet radiation
hydrogen the other product of this
chemical reaction floats away into space
oxygen meanwhile which is a heavier
element settles close to the surface
apart from large amounts of water ice
other elements found on ganymede's
Surface are carbon dioxide sulfur
dioxide sulfates and some other organic
substances they may well have originated
in the depths of the subsurface ocean
but the mechanisms of their settling on
the satellite surface are still not
clear
Callisto is another celestial object
potentially just as attractive for life
this satellite is Jupiter's second
largest one and lies furthest from it
its diameter measures
4820 kilometers almost like that of
Mercury
Callisto is encased in an icy shell as
thick as 80 to 150 kilometers and it is
highly likely that there is a salty
ocean concealed under it containing
large amounts of ammonia and other
substances
[Music]
the estimates of its depth range from 50
to 300 kilometers and its temperature is
around 251 Kelvin or 21 degrees Celsius
below zero according to most models due
to impurities and high pressure the
water in the ocean should remain in its
liquid state
below the subsurface ocean there is
bound to be a layer of ice as stickers
around 300 kilometers and the satellite
score made up of water ice and rocks
lies still deeper down
callisto's surface is pockmarked with
craters spectral analysis of light
reflected from this celestial object
revealed not only water vapor and
silicon rocks but also ammonia carbon
dioxide sulfur iron and magnesium
compounds as well as stolens complex
organic polymers containing nitrogen
these brightly colored substances form
on the surfaces of celestial bodies a
result produced by ultraviolet radiation
Callisto happens to lie too far from
Jupiter to get more heat from it besides
the tidal influence exerted by the giant
neighbor isn't enough to deform the
satellite although friction in the
process would heat it up
also most of these bodies made up of ice
whereas it is preferable that they
should be solid rocks which would
saturate water with elements vital for
life forms to originate
with the diversity of chemical compounds
here rather modest and the temperature
quite low it hardly improves chances of
Life evolving here
still this possibility should of course
not be ruled out yet
the most promising of Jupiter's
satellites in terms of searching for
alien life is Europa the smallest of
Jupiter's four Galilean moons it is just
a bit smaller than our moon the
equatorial temperature on this Celestial
body is 110 Kelvin or 163 degrees
Celsius below zero
at the pearls temperatures may drop to
50 Kelvin or 223 degrees Celsius below
zero
Europa is tidally locked to Jupiter
facing it with the same side only
however its rotation isn't synchronized
ideally there are deviations from the
calculated trajectory
this may mean that there is a liquid
layer between europa's surface and core
this assumption is confirmed by
observation of interaction between the
satellite and Jupiter's magnetic field
carried out by the Galileo space probe
in the late 20th century apart from that
analysis of crevices europa's surface is
covered with shows that the satellites
crust moved 80 degrees with respect to
the interior this would have been
impossible without a liquid layer
between them the massive neighbor exerts
a strong influence over Europa by
causing powerful tidal waves in its
subsurface ocean this way the satellite
is heated still more by internal
friction
estimates show that the temperature in
europa's interior is high enough for an
ocean of water to be in liquid state
its depth May reach a hundred kilometers
and its volume may be twice that of the
global ocean on our Earth
Europa is covered with an even layer of
exceptionally smooth and clear ice the
highest elements of relief Tower just
several hundred meters above the surface
the thickness of the icy crust may be
anything from 10 to 30 kilometers
although the satellite surface is
streaked with a Whole Net of long and
deep cracks some of them may well reach
as deep as the subsurface layer of water
thus the ice at the bottom of these
Ravines is valuable material for
studying the inner makeup of Europa
another peculiar feature of this moon is
powerful ice-celled Vapor geezers
they open up only when Europa is at its
furthest point from Jupiter with the
height of the spurts reaching as much as
200 kilometers
these giant jets are made up of water
vapor which incidentally is unexpectedly
clean
it is still not known for certain
whether the gizas have anything to do
with the ocean in europa's interior or
they come from gargantuan Lakes embedded
in the satellites icy crust
today the composition of the subsurface
Ocean on the satellite is estimated by
analyzing the ice covering the inner
part of its largest craters
only a really large object is capable of
breaking the thick layer of the ice
clean through on impact
after the icy crust is broken the water
in the subsurface ocean at the impact
site freezes and forms the bottom of a
crater
spectral analysis of the craters reveals
magnesium sulfur and iron compounds as
well as hydrogen peroxide and strong
acids
this demonstrates that there is a vast
diversity of minerals in the satellite's
concealed hydrosphere
europa's atmosphere contains oxygen
which forms as a result of ultraviolet
radiation interacting with the ice water
on a Surface splitting the water into
oxygen and hydrogen the satellite's
atmosphere however is approximately a
trillion times as rarified as that of
our Earth still According to some
estimates a concentration of oxygen in
europa's subsurface ocean should be
sufficient for supporting single cell
aerobic life forms underwater volcanoes
should be their sources of energy and
food as they saturate water with sulfur
and Dion oxides
primitive organisms May attach
themselves to the bottom side of the ice
crust or Swim freely in water it was
even assumed that there may dwell
primitive multicellular organisms in the
europa's ocean
however this hypothesis appears to be
rather too presumptuous
in fact there is a great many species on
our Earth which would be able to survive
in the estimated conditions of europa's
subsurface ocean there are among them
not only bacteria resistant to harsh
environments but multicellular creatures
too for example tardigrades consequently
we cannot rule out the possibility of
primitive life originating in the depths
of this celestial object of its own
accord
unfortunately enough in spite of the
Keen interest we have in Jupiter and its
satellites so far they have been
investigated only briefly and that by
spacecraft passing them on our way
elsewhere
no Landings on the gas giant satellites
have so far been attempted at the moment
the largest planet in our system is
being investigated by the Juno probe but
as soon as in July 2021 it will move on
to studying the Galilean moons the data
collected by Juno will undoubtedly be of
great importance and help get to the
bottom of processes taking place in
Jupiter's system
as for upcoming missions back in 2012
the European Space Agency announced
starting work on the juice project or
Jupiter icy Moon Explorer the mission of
the project is to explore in detail the
gas giant itself as well as Ganymede
Europa and Callisto juice will be
launched next year but will reach
Jupiter's environs early in 2029 the
mission is scheduled until the year 2033
before goes according to plan our
knowledge about the gas giant and its
satellites will be substantially
expanded
another big research project is NASA's
Europa clipper
this automatic probe is planned to lift
off the Earth's surface not later than
2023 and to reach Jupiter's system in
2032 the probe's objective is quite
predictably Europa in contrast to Jews
it is this Celestial body that Clipper
is supposed to focus on more closely
[Music]
approximately a hundred million years
ago
foreign
icy satellite approached Saturn too
closely
the gas giants extremely powerful tidal
forces shattered it into trillions of
small bits
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
obeying the overwhelming physical laws
these bits gradually spread out
embracing the planet in a primary ring
foreign
it was roughly a thousand times more
massive than Saturn's today's rings
[Music]
millions of years have passed since the
time of the disaster
since then some part of the destroyed
satellites fragments were swallowed up
by Saturn Without a Trace
other debris bombarded the surfaces of
its multiple satellites or else left the
environs of the gas giant altogether
foreign
this is one of the most well-grounded
scientific hypotheses today that account
for the origins and evolution of
Saturn's rings
[Music]
even after hundreds of years of
observations this tremendous structure
in space still hides a lot of Secrets
Saturn's rings do not have a clear-cut
border
the width of their visible part is about
as much as two hundred and eighty
thousand kilometers although there are
thinnest clusters of dust and rarified
gas Beyond these borders these
structure's diameter reaches 16 million
kilometers According to some estimates
although they cannot be seen from the
earth on account of their extremely low
density
in spite of the impressive Dimensions
the total mass of the Ring system is
quite small by space standards and is
estimated at 3 times 10 to the power of
19 kilograms
which is about 2 000 times lighter than
the moon
solid objects account for only three
percent or so of the structure's overall
volume
with a rest filled with rarified gas and
Cosmic dust
the discs surrounding Saturn is
conventionally divided into several
large rings however a rather powerful
optical telescope will reveal each of
them to be clearly made up of a large
number of thin circles separated by
narrow gaps these gaps form due to the
gravitational influence of both the
planet itself and its many satellites
some of them are as much as several
hundred kilometers wide
even though Saturn's disk reflects
several times more sunlight than the gas
giant itself some rings are next to
impossible to see
for example the d-ring the closest to
the planet which consists of tiniest
water ice crystals and Frozen methane
its upper border is posited to be
located 16 500 kilometers above the
planet's conventional surface
as for its inner pot the ring has no
clear-cut border and gradually fuses
with Saturn's atmosphere
next to it is the brighter and more
massive searing which is approximately
17 500 kilometers wide
it is comprised of space objects
measuring up to two meters and which
make up just
0.033 percent of the disk's overall Mass
the brightest and most outstanding part
of the disc is located further and is
designated the b-ring
it begins roughly 34 000 kilometers
above the surface of the gas giant and
its width reaches 25
000 kilometers the thickness of the
larger part of the Ring does not measure
over 5 to 10 meters while its outer part
forms a vertical Rim towering up to two
and a half kilometers high
the outermost visible ring of Saturn
begins 64 000 kilometers above the
planet's surface
it is roughly 14 600 kilometers wide
harboring not only comparatively large
ice bits of 10 meters or more but some
satellites as well such as pan daphnis
and others
the existence of such large objects may
prove the theory of reinformation
following the destruction of the ice
satellite
alternatively they may have formed at a
later time as a result of smaller
fragments colliding and merging
Beyond this part of the disc there lie
the almost unobservable F G and D rings
which formed from cosmic dust and
rarified gas
it goes without saying that most of
Saturn's large satellites actively
interact with the Rings
traveling as far as 179
000 kilometers away to the region of the
so-called e-ring the celestial body
dubbed Enceladus is to be found with a
diameter measuring just 500 kilometers
it does not qualify as one of the gas
giants largest satellites but it stands
out for other reasons
the point is that Enceladus is one of
the few celestial bodies in our system
where there are clear manifestations of
cryovolcanic activity
analysis of the observed emissions
proves that there is a notion of liquid
water under its surface
mathematical modeling shows that its
temperature measures from 45 degrees
Celsius below zero in the upper layers
to zero degrees at the bottom
due to high content of dissolved salts
and ammonia the ocean does not freeze
over even in Sub-Zero temperatures with
the icy Shield about two kilometers
thick covering and thermally insulating
it
the celestial body's surface temperature
is about 75 Kelvin or 198 degrees
Celsius below zero
its atmosphere is extremely rarefied and
is 91 water vapor other elements making
it up on nitrogen carbon dioxide and
methane
powerful geysers that erupt from time to
time through cracks and the icy crust to
the satellite regularly supplied its
atmosphere with chemical elements but
the celestial body's weak gravity is not
enough to prevent the atmosphere from
floating away
the upper region of the atmosphere is
constantly losing some amount of
particles that go to sustain the e-ring
on the other hand Enceladus constantly
captures material from the space around
it thus ensuring its peculiar chemical
balance
it is now that Giza activity of the
celestial object depends on its orbital
movement
it is likely that Saturn's tide of
forces deform the satellite's icy Shield
causing it to crack in multiple places
and to erupt
it is also known that the cryogiza's
emissions contain elaborate organic
molecules which may mean that the
conditions in the subsurface ocean May
hypothetically be favorable for the
Genesis of biological life
also the gas Giant's fifth largest and
most massive satellite tethis can be
seen approximately 300 000 kilometers
away from it it is peculiar for sharing
the same orbit with two other celestial
objects telesto and calypso
they're located the so-called stable
LaGrange points with telestos 60 degrees
ahead of the main satellite in its
movement along the orbit while Calypso
on the contrary lags 60 degrees behind
unlike the massive spherical tethers
these celestial bodies are not that
large and are regular in shape they
measure roughly 20 to 30 kilometers in
diameter with their overall Mass just
several trillion tons which is modest by
space standards
interestingly modeling shows that
Calypso and telesto could not have
originally formed in the same orbit with
a more massive body following it which
means that they arrived to join it at a
much later time
as for tethers it is a celestial object
with a diameter measuring about 1060
kilometers made up of mostly water ice
with some rocky impurities in its
composition the most outstanding feature
of its relief is the giant impact crater
Odysseus its diameter measures around
450 kilometers which is about twice as
small as the diameter of tethers itself
its depth reaches as far down as three
kilometers
there is also an easily noticeable Chasm
of enormous proportions on the satellite
surface which is called the Ithaca
chasma
it is as long as about 2 000 kilometers
that is about a third of the celestial
body's circumference in as much as a
hundred kilometers wide as for its depth
it ranges from three thousand to five
thousand meters and the bottom is
pockmarked with a great number of
craters and minor irregularities of the
surface
according to one of the theories about
it the Ithaca Chasm formed as a result
of deathas's subsurface ocean freezing
over
on turning into ice the water expanded
in size and erupted through the
satellite's outer crust
another assumption about the chasm has
to do with the Odysseus crater it is
thought that the impact waves traveled
across the entire surface of the
satellite and caused a powerful
resonance around its circumference
as a result deaths's crust cracked
forming this incredibly large chasm
still further from Saturn there lies its
largest satellite Titan which also
boasts quite a number of Highly unusual
features
with a diameter measuring
5152 kilometers it is in fact the second
largest satellite in the solar system
with Ganymede held in the first place
it is also remarkable for being 5.5
percent bigger than Mercury
Titan is also the only satellite in the
solar system with a dense atmosphere and
bodies of liquid on its surface
since Titan lies quite far from the Sun
the temperature of the celestial body is
quite low at around 94 Kelvin or 180
degrees Celsius below zero having said
that in spite of its comparatively small
Mass Titan is capable of sustaining an
atmosphere which is one and a half times
denser than that of the Earth
nitrogen accounts for over 98 of the
atmosphere's chemical composition with
methane and other gases making up the
rest
exposed to solar wind nitrogen and
hydrocarbon compounds and atmosphere's
upper layers transform into more complex
organic substances which subsequently
slowly settle on Titan's surface due to
the impermeable hydrocarbon smog the
satellite surface is unobservable in the
optical range
according to the most plausible model of
titans in a structure there is a massive
Rocky core at its center with a diameter
measuring about
3400 kilometers
it is embedded in a thick layer of
exceptionally dense ice which forms the
bottom of a cool salty ocean containing
up to 10 percent of dissolved ammonia
is buried under a crust of water ice
mixed with methane hydrate which is many
kilometers thick in temperatures as low
as that the ice has properties identical
to those of a solid substance and forms
mountain ridges and elevations on the
surface
as for lowlands and chasmas they are
filled with lakes of liquid ethane and
other hydrocarbons
solar wind and Saturn's extremely
powerful magnetic field constantly
stripped Titan of its atmosphere however
its internal processes keep replenishing
it so the process of losing it may take
billions upon billions of years
when the Sun hits the red giant phase it
will be capable of vaporizing
hydrocarbon Haze and melt the Eternal
ices and Titan after this the satellites
will become a more favorable place for
the Genesis of life
however it will not happen for a while
yet
of course Saturn's system does not end
there
[Music]
Pluto is about 40 astronomical units
away from the Sun
and is a dark and indistinguishable
object
this distance Celestial body follows a
rather elongated orbit around the center
of the solar system completing it every
248 Earth years
we know that Pluto's radius is
1188 kilometers which means that it is
noticeably inferior in size not only to
all the planets of the solar system but
also to some of their satellites
including the Moon
at the same time observations of the
celestial body's proper motion made it
possible to calculate its mass with a
high degree of accuracy
turned out to be small
only 1.3 times 10 to the power of 22
kilograms or 18 of the lunar Mass
it is easy to see that Pluto is much
more similar to small celestial bodies
such as Eris Ceres or sedna in terms of
its characteristics this is the reason
why it topped the list of dwarf planets
in 2006
due to its long and elongated trajectory
Pluto has a long orbital cycle
only in 1989 did the planetoid first
pass its orbit perihelion since its
discovery
approaching the Sun as close as 29.7
astronomical units
since then this distance has been
continuously increasing and will reach
its greatest value in the year 2113. by
that time the dwarf planet will be near
its aphelion which is 49.3 astronomical
units away from the center of our system
thus Pluto is a very distant and dim
space object
that is the reason why it cannot be seen
from Earth with the naked eye and even
in images from the Hubble Space
Telescope the dwarf planet looks like a
murky Brown disc without any surface
details
of course in such conditions it is
almost impossible to study the celestial
body properly
to solve this problem the New Horizons
unmanned orbital station was sent to
Pluto in 2006.
it took a long nine and a half years to
reach his destination on its way it
beamed back to us detailed images of
Jupiter it wasn't until 2015 that the
spacecraft finally reached the main
object of its Mission as it flew past
Pluto the station made about 400
observations collecting more than six
gigabytes of information and it took
more than a year to transmit this large
amount of data to Earth
unfortunately the probe's trajectory did
not allow photographing the entire
surface of the dwarf planet the fact is
that New Horizons did not enter into an
orbit around Pluto but circled round
Pluto in order to be able to explore
other space objects
before moving on to the celestial bodies
terrain features we need to understand
its internal structure
according to the currently accepted
model Pluto has a massive core with a
diameter of about 1 700 kilometers
consisting of a mixture of various forms
of water ice and rocks in its Center it
is surrounded by 300 kilometer ice
mantle there are probably tectonic
processes running in the mantle and in
the moment they're quite understudied
the mantle in its turn is covered by a
crust which is a mixture of crystallized
Gases such as nitrogen methane and
carbon monoxide
According to some assumptions Pluto's
core May generate enough heat to melt
some of the icy mantle
in this case deep beneath the surface of
the planetoid there should hide a very
salty and toxic ocean containing large
amounts of dissolved ammonia as for the
surface temperature of the dwarf planet
it is very low and is not over 60 Kelvin
or 213 degrees Celsius below zero
our journey around Pluto will start at
the most outstanding and well studied
feature of its relief tombow Reggio
this vast area is located in the
equatorial zone of the planetoid and is
shaped like a hard sketch this
resemblance earned the region its
informal nickname the heart its size
reaches 2 300 kilometers which means
that the plane occupies about a quarter
of the celestial body's entire area
tombow reggio's surface is not
homogeneous thus there is a smooth and
Light plane in its western part known as
sputnikplanetia whose diameter measures
1492 kilometers an elevation map will
reveal this region to be a vast lowland
area
it is covered with a thick layer of
nitrogen ice as well as carbon monoxide
and solid methane these substances have
a light coloring which makes some parts
of the plane reflect up to 90 percent
with the light falling on them
there are also virtually no craters
which means that the region is very
young in geological terms
according to the main hypothesis
Sputnik lenisha formed about a hundred
million years ago when Pluto experienced
a collision with a large Celestial body
as a result a huge impact crater
appeared it was filled with contents of
the hypothetical inner ocean of the
dwarf planet which rapidly froze there
some typical features of the relief of
the plane can serve as evidence of this
for example there are quite a number of
smooth surface areas on it ranging from
20 to 30 kilometers in size with hills
and depressions concentrated on the
borders between them this kind of
structure resembles convection cells
which appear in any fluid heated From
Below
this may serve as an indirect
confirmation of the hypothesis of
Pluto's warm interior
tombow Reggio is surrounded by
comparatively high mountain ridges
thus Hillary Monty's lying to the west
from sputnikplanetia reach three and a
half kilometers in height townsing
Montes are located in the southern part
of the heart
some of them Tower as high as over six
kilometers above the dwarf planet's
average surface level which makes this
Ridge the tallest one found on Pluto
remarkably these rocks are likely to be
made up mostly of Water Ice
and in temperatures as low as here on
Pluto water ice is a solid as rock
moving a little further south we can see
a deep Basin surrounded by Massive
motorlayered Ridges of ice and rock it
is assumed that it may be the vent of an
ancient cryo volcano and the rock around
it is its numerous Frozen eruptions
their chemical composition is of great
interest to science because once it is
known the peculiarities of Pluto's inner
makeup may be studied the eastern part
of tombau Reggio is darker in addition
its surface is pockmarked with a great
number of craters which means that this
region is by far Elder than Sputnik
planisha moving further east along the
Equator we will see a chain of dark
spots hundreds of kilometers in diameter
these objects are called maculas and are
named after dark deities of various
cultures for example one of them is
named balrog
together they form a giant structure
called the brass knuckles encompassing
the celestial body along the Equator the
maculas are separated by high mountain
ranges and their surface is cut by Deep
crevices reaching hundreds of kilometers
in length Cthulhu macula stretches to
the west from tombau Reggio it is the
largest dark spot on Pluto measuring
almost 3 000 kilometers its surface
reflects not more than 30 percent of the
light shed on it which is a stark
contrast with a bright and light
sputnikplanetia close by
there is still no reliable information
about what maculars are it is assumed
that their dark color is due to a high
content of tholines combined with a
relatively large concentration of impact
craters this indicates that maculas are
remarkably old it is also known that the
surface of Cthulhu macula is
heterogeneous thus its relief in the
western part is undulating
the central part is a smooth plane and
the eastern part is covered with
mountains and craters
foreign
leaving the Grim spot of Cthulhu macula
behind us let's head north here lies
Lowell Reggio the vast Valley
surrounding Pluto's North Pole
surprisingly it is this place that is
currently the most illuminated part of
the celestial body's surface
the point is that Pluto's axis of
rotation has a very large tilt with
respect to the plane of its orbit so in
its movement it found itself facing the
sun with its North Pole it is assumed
that is for this reason that the density
of Pluto's atmosphere has tripled over
the past 30 years despite the growing
distance from the Sun
it is likely that the sun's Rays
evaporate nitrogen ice settle to the
pole which goes into the dwarf planet's
atmosphere
in its orbital motion Pluto has a number
of peculiarities compared to the planets
of the solar system in addition to the
fact that its orbit has a noticeable
tilt to the ecliptic plane the planetoid
itself constantly performs cyclic
oscillations near a certain point
this is due to the presence of a large
satellite gravitationally affecting the
dwarf planet it is called Sharon and its
mass is 1.52 times 10 to the power of 21
kilograms
which is more than 11 percent the mass
of Pluto itself
as a consequence both celestial bodies
orbit a common Mass center between them
they're tidally locked to each other so
they face each other with the same sides
at all times
are like plutaras the surface of its
satellite is noticeably darker and shows
an abundance of water ice which is mixed
with methane and nitrogen only in some
regions
in addition to Sharon there are several
other satellites but all of them are
much smaller and irregular in shape
Nixon Hydra discovered in 2005 measure
several tens of kilometers and kerberus
and sticks which were discovered later
are not over 16 kilometers in diameter
all of these celestial bodies consist
mainly of water ice and were probably
captured by Pluto's Gravity from the
Kuiper belt
unfortunately a significant part of
Sharon was not caught in the field of
view of the New Horizons probe's cameras
but many curious terrain features can be
found on the visible surface of the
celestial body
for example to the south of the Equator
that lies a vast region called Vulcan
plenum its area is not known precisely
but it is not less than 400 000 square
kilometers which is comparable with the
size of an average European country
here the highest Summit of Sharon can be
found kubrik Mars its diameter measures
around 40 kilometers and according to
some estimates its height reaches 4000
meters in addition the mountain is
surrounded by a wide circular moat as it
were up to two kilometers deep According
to some assumptions Kubrick mons May in
fact be a cryo volcano in this case it
is very likely that their air around it
has sunk under its own weight due to the
amping of the underground reservoir to
the north stretches the vast Oz Terror
the surface of which is bookmarked with
many craters it is separated from Vulcan
plenum by a system of giant Ledges and
crevices with a total height of about a
kilometer the largest of them is
Serenity kasma which is 200 kilometers
long with a width varying from 40 to 50
kilometers it can be as deep as 7
kilometers and it is difficult to
explore its bottom because because of
the thick Shadows cast by the steep
slopes
further north yet near the very pole
there is the giant Mordor macular its
diameter reaches 475 kilometers and its
origin is still debatable according to
the dominant hypothesis today nitrogen
and methane floating from Pluto's
atmosphere were trapped by Sharon's
gravity and so settled at its poles
after exposure to ultraviolet radiation
they turned into tholins and gradually
concentrated in the ice of the celestial
body this assumption needs verification
which will be an object of future
missions
Sharon largely remains a mystery to us
because its research is only just
starting
although the Pluto Sharon system is
undoubtedly one of the most interesting
structures in the solar system it is
still understudied
unfortunately the New Horizons probe
left its environs long ago and the
celestial bodies themselves are rapidly
moving away from us taking their secrets
along
at the moment the probe is more than 50
astronomical units away from the Earth
and from time to time beams back to us
some extremely important data by about
2030 all of its systems will eventually
fail and the probe will be left all
alone in the chilling recesses of space
[Music]
roughly half a year before this video
was posted on the 15th of April 2021 the
automatic space probe New Horizons
became the fifth spacecraft in the
history of the humanity to go beyond the
point of 50 astronomical units from the
Sun it was the Voyages that had crossed
this mug before with the probes Pioneer
10 and Pioneer 11 the first ever to do
so
none of these space Wanderers are likely
to ever return to the Earth
with some of them still active on their
missions others have gone quiet forever
spacecraft New Horizons
start of mission 19th of January 2006
distance to Earth 52 astronomical units
Spade
14 kilometers per second or three
astronomical units per year
main goal Pluto and Sharon
mission status successfully completed
condition operational
just like most other interplanetary
space probes New Horizons performed a
gravity-assist maneuver near Jupiter
before setting out to its Target
not only did it greatly boost the
spacecraft's speed but also allowed it
to capture high quality images of the
largest planet in the solar system
alongside its satellites besides the
probes cameras captured the first video
ever of an erupting volcano on the
surface of Jupiter's satellite IO after
the gravity boost had been completed the
probe made for the main target Pluto
the spacecraft reached the planetoid's
environs in January 2015. the mission's
main goal was to explore Pluto and
Sharon from different perspectives that
involved taking photos of and mapping
these remote space object surfaces
in addition the probe estimated the
magnetic fields values and the solar
wind activity close to the objects and
collected information about their
atmospheres and surface reflection
properties
it goes without saying that the program
also involved search for Pluto's as yet
undetected satellites and more accurate
measurements of Pluto's Orbit's
parameters having completed the main
mission the probe continued to be useful
it flew Beyond Pluto's orbit and went on
to explore objects in the Kuiper belt
that is how images of kwawa R1 and
arakoth were produced thanks to the
probe's cameras the distances to the
star's Proxima Centauri and wolf 359
were measured unfortunately the
radioisotope generator on board the
spacecraft is expected to start running
low from 2026 and eventually all the
meters will switch off one after another
New Horizons will continue on its way
beyond the boundaries of the solar
system and by the year 2038 the distance
between the probe and the sun will have
grown to be a hundred astronomical units
by that time the energy generator on
board the spacecraft will have stopped
operating completely and it will be
impossible to get any connection with it
following a hyperbolic orbit New
Horizons will exit our system never to
come back
the same thing happened with two other
probes Pioneer 10 and Pioneer 11. they
hit an escaped trajectory from the solar
system a while ago
in fact they were the first automatic
space probes ever to be sent into
Interstellar Space by humans
spacecraft pioneer 10. start of mission
3rd of March 1972 distance to Earth
127 astronomical units Spade
approximately 12 kilometers per second
or two and a half astronomical units per
year
main goal Jupiter
mission status successfully completed
condition not operational
the spacecraft reached Jupiter's system
on the 4th of December 1973 after
completing a
641-day journey through space during the
mission images of the gas giant surface
and its largest satellites were beamed
back to the earth and the planet's
atmospheric composition and magnetic
field were gauged in addition Jupiter
was found to emit two and a half times
more thermal energy than it receives
from the Sun the data unique at the time
became the basis for understanding the
makeup of gas giants and their
satellites
the trajectory of the second probe
Pioneer 11 through space passed Jupiter
2 but its main target was the other gas
giant of our system
Saturn
the probe's scientific instruments gauge
the planet's magnetic field and the
cameras on board took quite a few
snapshots not only of the gas giant
itself and its system of rings but also
two of its satellites Titan and mimus
according to the estimates the current
distance between Pioneer 11 and the
center of our system is around 106
astronomical units
on completing their main mission both
probes continued on their way moving
further and further away from the Sun
unfortunately both of them are out of
range now with the last signal from
Pioneer 10 received back in 2003 the
last signal from Pioneer 11 was received
in 1995.
supposedly both of them are now rapidly
moving beyond the boundaries of the
solar system
incidentally having no chance of ever
catching up with either of the two
probes we're going to talk about next
the Pioneers were launched at a much
earlier date
spacecraft Voyager 1
start of mission
5th of September 1977.
distance to Earth
154 astronomical units
speed around 17 kilometers per second or
3.6 astronomical units per year
main goal Jupiter and Saturn
mission status
successfully completed
condition not fully operational
the contribution of Voyager 1 to the
Solar System's exploration can hardly be
overestimated
it is thanks to this probe that several
New Jupiter satellites were discovered
alongside its ring system which was big
news
the voyager's cameras captured volcano
eruptions on iO and provided hard
evidence that Jupiter's Great Red Spot
is an enormous storm the probe beamed
back hundreds of photos of the largest
planet of our solar system and its
satellites
after the spacecraft crossed Neptune's
orbit the meters on board sent back a
great amount of valuable data about
Interstellar plasma Voyager 1 left both
the Kuiper belt and the heliopause
behind a long while ago and is now
rapidly crossing the area of the Solar
System's scattered disc making for the
inner boundary of the hypothetical old
Cloud it is not only the remotest
man-made object in space but also the
fastest of all the spacecraft on their
way to exit our system being the first
space probe to have traveled that far
from the center of the solar system
Voyager 1 offered scientists a unique
opportunity to study the heliopause
this is the area around our sun where
solar wind pressure and Interstellar gas
pressure balance when the charged
particles emitted by the star collide
with rarified plasma elaborate
structures form out of Elementary
particles and magnetic fields
studying them is crucial for
understanding processes taking place in
the universe
unfortunately by around the year 2025
the power of the radioisotope
thermoelectric generators on board the
probe will have run out completely and
the connection will have been lost in
300 years Voyager 1 is estimated to
reach the inner boundary of the
hypothetical odd Cloud it will take the
spacecraft approximately 30 000 years to
go clean through and after that it will
fly beyond the boundaries of the solar
system ten thousand years later still
the probe will fly by the star glisa 445
at a distance of 1.6 light years and
then it will eventually get lost in the
infinite depths of outer space
[Music]
speaking about Voyager 1 we can't but
mention its twin launched from the earth
on the 20th of August 1977. Voyager 2
had Saturn Uranus and Neptune for its
targets but it also approached Jupiter
for a gravity boost as the images taken
by this probe that allowed scientists to
assume that there are subsurface oceans
on Ganymede and Europa
on reaching Saturn Voyager 2 gauged the
gas Giant's temperature and magnetic
field and discovered several new
satellites it goes without saying that
lots of snapshots were taken of both
Saturn's surface and its rings
next in line on the probe's way were
Uranus and Neptune the flyby yielded a
great number of unique snapshots and in
total 17 of the two Planet satellites
were discovered also it was found that
both Uranus and Neptune have ring
systems
under Neptune's gravitational influence
the spacecraft changed its trajectory
and left the ecliptic plane this meant
that Voyager 2 wouldn't be able to
approach the other objects in the solar
system but it still had other exciting
things to look forward to thus the probe
was to collect invaluable data about
Interstellar plasma and Cosmic Wind as
well as to measure distances to stars
and explore the heliosphere
probe is currently as far as 128
astronomical units away from the center
of our system with a distance grabbing
by 15.37 kilometers every second
it's going to take it around 42 000
years to approach Ross 248. a dim Red
Dwarf in the constellation Andromeda
the minimal distance between Voyager 2
and the star will be about 1.7 light
years and around 300 000 years since its
launch chances are it will fly by Sirius
at a distance of 4.3 light years
unfortunately it is impossible to
distinguish such a tiny object from the
earth that far away
we live at the dawn of space exploration
and interplanetary space probes are just
Mankind's first timid steps in exploring
the infinite Universe it is hard to
predict their fate they may be smashed
on collision with the celestial body or
they may be recaptured by our distant
descendants who will have advanced into
Stellar travel Technologies to the point
of being able to catch up with the
probes
for all we know they might recover them
from space and put on display in a
museum
but it is more likely that the fragile
apparatuses are destined to drift on for
years and years through the lifeless
expanses
and millions of years later
radioactive rays and rare particles of
cosmic dust whizzing through the probes
time and time again will eventually wear
them down to threadbare debris to be
scattered across the depths of the
universe Without a Trace
there are at least 200 billion stars in
our galaxy at the very least
some of them have no planetary systems
While others could challenge our sun in
terms of diversity of the bodies
orbiting them the depths of the Milky
Way are home to not less than a trillion
planets most of which are still waiting
for their discoveries
and this means that our journey is only
just starting and your support is a
potent motivational factor for it to
continue and bring us to the remotest
worlds
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]